We gotta figure out a way to make it so
we just have a white hole,
one button thing where everything syncs
up with one button to so possible one
day maybe.
We live right now with live,
live,
live.
How are you sir?
Yeah,
not too bad.
Welcome.
Thanks for coming man.
Appreciate it.
Yeah,
no worries.
Thanks so much for having me.
Sam Harris is going to be with us,
but he flaked out last minute.
He's busy,
man.
Yeah,
he's a busy man.
I'm so.
I'm,
I'm interested to talk to you about a
bunch of things,
but one of the big ones is this idea of
effective altruism and this is something
that you really promote to the point
where,
I don't know if this is true,
but I read this about you,
that everything that you make over
$36,000
a year,
you donate.
Yeah,
that's right.
So wow.
Yeah.
So everything above,
technically it's anything above 20,000
pounds from 2009 Oxford,
so just inflation,
cost of living changes and stuff,
but that's about $36,000.
So you've just sort of decided that,
which is by the way,
the one percent for the whole world?
Yeah.
Not quite two percent.
I'll be in the top,
still be in the top two percent.
Even despite that,
it was 34,000.
I think $34,000
puts you in a top one percent.
I think it's $55,000.
That was a change and maybe since
trump's been in office,
but it's a,
it's,
you know,
what you're doing is,
uh,
if that's the case,
that's a,
that's a very charitable thing.
Yeah.
And it's also,
I mean it's most of my income over the
course of my life,
like especially as an academic,
you know,
going to an tons though,
since the effect of altruism blew up,
you end up getting things like speaking
fees and give all that away as well.
It's going to end up probably being the
large majority of income,
of course,
of my life.
Do you ever like want to buy something
and be like,
shit,
if I wasn't so goddamn generous I'd be
able to get this.
You know,
I never do.
I like basically never think that,
yeah,
I think like this,
like I feel like in contemporary society
we just get bombarded with marketing
stuff all the time saying like,
oh,
you really need this thing if you're
going to have a good life.
And I think like an almost every case,
that's just not true.
I think the psychological evidence just
shows that once you go above a certain
level of income,
um,
additional money just has a very small
impact on your happiness.
And in my own case,
like the things that make me happy.
I like being surrounded by friends.
That's the gym membership,
that's like $40 a month or something.
It's not very much I can afford that.
Being able to work and you know,
why I really am passionate about and I
already have that.
So my life is just so good in so many
ways and I feel like there's so much of
a focus on money and how money is the
key to happiness and it's just,
I think it's just all bullshit basically
what's definitely some bullshit in it.
And I,
I see that a lot in my neighborhood
because I live where white people go to
breed and they,
they,
they go to breed and they,
they sit down and they just talk about
things.
They talk about Range Rovers and certain
watches and certain purses and shoes and
yeah.
And it becomes this constant.
The amazing thing is just how you adapt.
So it's called the hedonic treadmill.
The richer you are,
the richer you need to be.
Oh yeah.
So I was once part of a conversation,
um,
I was going to give a talk and um,
I was going to like a family and was on
the kind of the private jet in fact.
And the conversation was discussion of
different private jets in which private
jets are better than so.
And this other person has this really
nice private jet and it just means that
like at no stage do you ever lose the
like,
oh,
I could just have this nicer thing.
No,
because you can get to the point where
you want a jumbo jet,
like one of those Quantas air buses and
house.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure that one of those Richard
Branson type character characters
probably has something like that.
Yeah,
that's totally.
It seems to get to this.
You hit this critical mass stage where
you,
you know,
like these billionaire characters where
they start buying $100,000,000
yachts,
$400,000,000
yachts and what is the most expensive
Yada believe it's a half a billion
dollars or more incredible.
Yeah.
You need to have a staff to take care of
it the whole time.
And if it ever.
The thing is,
I think if I had a car that would make
my life worse because not only to be
stressing about this,
like what if it gets damaged?
Like I feel bad that I'm not using it.
Yeah.
I would imagine.
And less.
Well I guess not though,
because if you look at this,
oh Jesus Christ,
it's a billion billion dollars in a
year.
The streets of Monaco is what it's
called and it is $1,000,000,000.
Go to that thing.
Oh,
that's it.
Oh my God.
It's a,
it's a neighborhood.
I think some floating neighborhood.
I think on all of these things,
you should have the place,
the cost with how many bed nets you
could buy for children in sub Saharan
Africa.
Oh,
well that's just ridiculous.
Hold on.
Go up one once a one point 2 billion.
Scroll up.
Estimated price.
Oh my God.
The eclipse.
Oh,
forefront.
50 million to one point.
$2 billion.
That's like when you go to get it made
and you go like,
how much is it going to cost me?
And like,
between four $50 million and one point
$2 billion.
You're like,
oh,
you know,
normal,
normal shit.
Fucking change.
That is fucking insane.
Look at that God damn thing.
I mean that.
It's the.
Oh it's a replica of the Monaco Grand
Prix track.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
So you can drive around on your yacht at
a ridiculous rate of speed.
So this guy probably has like a Ferrari.
They go all over the surface of his
crazy yacht.
Okay,
let's get a fake beach.
But it hasn't been sold yet.
Oh,
it doesn't actually owned yet,
I don't think.
Oh,
okay.
Interesting.
Who buys that?
They're going to get love attention
where there are enough people.
There's a bunch of those people.
I mean,
I don't want anyone to billion.
That's probably.
There's only a couple of thousand people
in the world who are worth that much.
Really?
Yeah.
If somebody's willing to sink the whole
fortunate.
How many billionaires do you think there
are worldwide?
Let's guess he and a half thousand
dollars million.
There's three and a half thousand
dollars.
You're.
You sound very confident.
I think it's about that.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's,
that's a large number.
That is kind of crazy.
Three and a half thousand people that
have more than $100.
Million dollars and here's a whole will
macaskill at over 35,000.
Cuts it off,
but then half of that 1800,
1800 people.
Oh,
you're happy.
Glad we've got.
Well,
no,
I'm just happy we've got fact.
Check it on.
Connected health statistics.
That's a lot of money,
man,
but it is one of those weird things
where I do not think that money equates
to happen.
One of the things that money does do is
it alleviates the stress of bills,
but a lot of those stress of bills can
be alleviated by not buying as many
things.
Right.
So like a lot of the stress of bills
that people have is sort of self imposed
stress.
Like you get a mortgage for a very large
house,
you have car payments,
you have all these different things that
you're paying for.
So that kind of money stress that some
people put themselves under is actually
not really necessary.
Right.
So if you broke it down to what do you
actually need,
just need a nice place to live where
it's not crime Britain and it's safe.
You need a bed.
What else do you need?
Food.
You need food.
Exercise.
You one of those.
No TV dudes.
Do you have a tail?
Well,
I watched Netflix.
I just finished veep,
which I love.
Is it good?
Yeah,
it gets better.
The first season's on so good,
but they don't have that kind of
patience.
Seasons.
Oh yeah.
I just got addicted.
Even if I want something and I think
it's awful,
I still just.
I will get addicted right away.
I have to watch olefins.
Yeah.
I've liked the most compulsive
personality.
Have you seen house of cards?
I have not seen a deliberately.
Not Stock Show.
Yeah.
That's a good show.
Like game of thrones makes my life
worse.
I like hate it really.
I think it's amazing television,
but I find it to so distressing because
you still have to watch it all the time.
Why do you find it distressing?
Just like the violence,
the violence,
people's gang.
The heads popped and stung.
Oh,
that one with the mountain?
Yeah.
That's the one that really stays with
me.
That's rough.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm.
It gives me a lot of anxiety because I
know there's only two seasons left and
the next season is one coming up.
It's only seven episodes and the final
season is only six.
I'm so happy about that.
It's like it's not making me happy.
Well,
I'm not very happy about that at all.
It's like someone saying they're going
to stop selling heroin or something.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm going to have to get hooked on
Oxycontin and that's what I feel I'm
going to have to watch the whole season
all over again or the whole series.
Um,
so you have a television,
you have a computer.
I'm sure you have the computer.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I like moving around two tons,
so I normally,
like I don't have a house,
but it wouldn't be convenient type of
house because I'm traveling so much to
you.
Brenda apartment or something and had an
apartment.
You live in England?
I live in oaks most of the time.
I spent quite a chunk of my time out in
the bay area.
I'm like significant part of our staff
and the nonprofits out there.
I've got lots of contacts still the
organizations about that.
So most of your time you,
it seems like you're spending working
for charitable organizations or.
Yeah,
so I have kind of three hats.
So one is an academic,
so I'm the festival oxides.
Second is this kind of more public
figure whether I'm talking about these
ideas through books or on this podcast
and so on.
And then third is I run a nonprofit
called the center for effective
altruism,
which is more about like finding the
best charities,
the ones that doing the most good is
going to help other people the most and
kind of promote them and try and get
people to give more and to give more
effectively.
Yeah.
We've gone over ineffective charities or
I shouldn't say ineffective,
but charities that are the way they're
structured,
when you look at how much money is
actually going towards the charity
itself and how much is going towards the
structure of the organization,
it's kind of crazy.
Yeah,
I mean I think so that's normally the
focus of ineffective cavities is on
like,
yeah,
how much is spent on overheads.
But I actually think that's not the most
important thing.
The most important thing is what's the
charity actually doing?
Like what's the actual program?
So one chata tea for the example that
I'm sure you'll find funny as a chatbot,
skilled homeopaths without borders and
it goes to Haiti and particularly on
disobedience like homeopathic
calamities,
um,
you know,
which don't work,
they don't provide any health benefit.
And even if at a zero percent overhead
cost,
so apps like spent nothing,
everything was volunteers.
It would still be bad child teach.
Those shouldn't be given to that Chata
tea.
This one I didn't know that that one
existed.
Yeah.
It's kind of small,
but I would imagine phil,
thankfully homeopaths without Borders
God.
But then there's some super effective
charities like paradigm that's saving a
life with flt three and a half thousand
dollars,
like the against malaria foundation.
Even if they were spending a bunch on
investigating what are the best areas to
focus on or like paying of that stuff
more.
If what you should just care about is
how much money you're putting in and
what you're getting is an outcome.
Right?
Well,
I think it's impossible for everyone to.
It's impossible for you to give $10 and
all $10 is going to go directly to the
charity because there's got to be
overhead,
there's got to be infrastructure,
there's got to be a bunch of people
working there,
rent costs.
But the question is,
at what point does it become kind of a
scam?
Because there are most certainly some
organizations that appear to be
charitable organizations but are really
kind of a scam.
Yeah,
there's definitely some.
So like the kid's wish network,
for example,
kind of like the make a wish foundation,
similar idea.
And they spent 99 percent of their
budget on fundraising.
So they were just like this kind of
chatter Ponzi scheme basically.
So they spend all their money on
fundraising itself.
Yeah.
To then invest in more fundraising and
one percent somehow or another gets out
there.
Yeah.
What does that.
Maybe it's not as high as 99 percent is
above 90 percent or something crazy.
So what does that money get to?
Like what do they do with the actual
money itself?
And then the idea that was
granting wishes for sick children.
Um,
so,
uh,
do you remember the San Francisco thing
with back kid?
It was like,
a bit like there was a big event,
lots of publicity around this kid,
a child that had some strange disorder.
Yeah.
So,
um,
the child,
I don't know the details.
I think the child had leukemia.
They have wished was that they wanted to
be Batman for the day.
[inaudible] this is a different thing.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
So they like the make a wish foundation
set up.
This um,
you know,
amazing store.
They were,
they got to kind of drive and a
batmobile and like have this a fantastic
day with it.
Basically Batman for the day kids which
network is doing basically the same
thing.
They find seriously sick kids often
terminally ill kids and say what one
thing would you want?
And we'll make it happen.
But at the,
I think the but there is a lot of focus
on like particularly bad charities,
you know,
the ones that really come up too is
completely dysfunctional.
But I think that's not actually the most
important message.
What's most important is just even among
the charities that kind of good,
even the ones that are making a
difference,
there's still a vast difference in the
impact that you have difference of
hundreds of thousands of times between
the penalties that are merely good and
there's ones that are really the very
best and that's by mainly dependent on
what program are they focusing on.
So what is there any charity that people
should avoid spending their money on?
Like are there other charities that you
feel like are just so ridiculously
ineffective?
Like,
yeah,
I mean like the ones we mentioned of
kids who wished network or homeopaths
without borders.
I'm the borders.
This is ridiculous.
It's like food.
Who on parade?
Just stop.
Yeah,
I mean there was another one.
I can't remember that but it does.
I'm a strategy without limits and with
that limit.
No,
it does.
I'm dolphin therapy for autistic
children which has no evidence of
working,
um,
but does actually just have some,
like the risk of the children's
learning.
So yeah,
so you can like chatty pick these
examples.
But the thing is that these aren't just
like not really representative in
general.
I think charities doing good.
Um,
but the question is just like in the
same way as if you're buying a product
for yourself,
you don't just want to get like,
you know,
a laptop as long as it's work.
So you want to find like what's the best
laptop I can get with my money?
Or if you're investing you want to not
just get like an okay to turn.
You want to say,
well what's the best to the attorney can
get.
Right.
So in that sense,
I think like the number of charities
that you think is just,
yeah,
this is literally competing for being
the most effective charity in the world.
That's actually fairly small.
So givewell for the examples a evaluates
it looks all sorts of different global
health and global development charities
and it's less of charities that's like,
yeah,
this is super good.
You should literally be donating to
them.
It's only seven charities long at the
moment.
Mine is up from last year when it was
only for travel to wow.
Seven charities.
That of how,
I mean,
what is the overall total of act of
charities?
It's got to be in the thousands,
hundreds of thousands,
I'm sure.
What got you involved in this?
So you're a young,
you seem like you should be playing
video games and skateboarding or
something.
I spent a lot of my teenage years
playing video games.
Yeah,
it was,
again,
compulsive personality.
I need the band myself from doing it.
So you're compulsive personalities now
going towards good things.
Yeah,
I manage the key was managing my life so
that the things I get really focused on
addicted.
I'm addicted to good things than bad.
Um,
so yeah,
it all started back in.
So I was back in high school.
I'm kind of undergraduate of being very
convinced by the arguments that this
philosopher,
Peter Singer,
oh,
I know Peter Singer,
he's like a radical animal rights
activist.
He has.
Yeah.
He has a few things.
Um,
and he had this argument,
which is that,
you know,
the way I tell the story is,
imagine I'm someone walks is walking
past a shallow pond and they see a child
drowning in that shallow pond and they
could run in and they could save the
child.
Butler willing a really nice suit suit
the costs like $3,000.
And so they say,
no,
I'm not going to save that child.
I'm just going to walk by and let it
down because I don't want to lose the
cost of this suit.
I normally say,
look in moral philosophy,
we have a technical term for people like
that they called assholes.
And uh,
the,
this is how I convey it in my seminars.
Um,
and obviously we all agree like,
yeah,
come on,
if it's just,
you could clearly save this child,
it's light in front of you.
You ought to do that.
The cost of $30,000
does not count.
But then what Peter Singer's insight is
it says,
well,
what's the difference between that
child?
It's right there in front of you and
that child that's in Subsaharan Africa
who you could save,
you'll never meet them for sure.
Um,
but you could still save their life with
just a few thousand dollars if you
donate it to a barely effective
nonprofit and he considers all the
different ways in which these cases
might be just analogous but decides
ultimately like,
no,
there's actually just know morally
relevant difference.
And so yeah,
we do just have an obligation to give
away at least a very significant
proportion of our income.
And I was really convinced by this kind
of on an intellectual level for many
years,
but I never really did anything about
it.
Uh,
and not until I went to Oxford to do a
postgraduate degree in philosophy.
And in the summer between that I needed
some money.
I worked as a fundraiser for care
international global development
charity.
So I was one of those annoying people in
the street who had kind of passed the
light,
can get in your way and then ask you to
donate $10 a month.
And it meant the all day.
Every day.
I was talking about like,
look,
this is the conditions of people in
extreme poverty,
we can do so much to help people at such
little cost to ourselves,
you know,
why are we not doing this?
And I was just over and over again kind
of getting these apathetic responses and
I was just getting so frustrated because
I just thought,
look,
these people just not living up to their
own values.
People killingly do Claire Care,
but there's some sort of block going on.
And then I thought,
well,
I'm going to do philosophy.
At the time I was planning to do like
philosophy of language,
logic,
very esoteric stuff.
And so I thought,
well,
I'm not living up to my own values.
Um,
I should really try and make a change.
And so I went to Oxford and I started
asking a whole bunch of different kind
of academics or what,
what's the impact of your work?
What kind of difference have you made?
And normally they were like,
I'm not really in it to make an impact.
I just got interested in these ideas and
that was pretty disheartening.
But I kept persisting until I met
another postgraduate student called Toby
Ord,
and he just blew me away because he had
also been convinced by these ideas,
but he'd gone one step further and he'd
said,
Yep,
I've made a commitment to give away
almost all of my income of the course of
my life,
about million pounds.
At the time,
he was living on 9,000
pounds,
saving 2000 pounds and donating 2000
pounds.
So he was like,
well,
really hardcore the thing as well as
actually taking these ideas and putting
into practice what really blew me away
was just how positive he was.
And he was.
It was not the.
He was kind of wearing his hair shirt
flagellating instead he was saying,
look,
this is an amazing way to live.
We have this amazing opportunity to do a
huge amount of goods to help so many
other people,
thousands of people.
It's actually a very low cost to
ourselves.
And me having that one person who also
kind of shared my worldview,
shared my ambitions,
just meant kind of gave that little
psychological block was lifted.
And it meant that I was like,
okay,
cool,
I'm on board first,
I can a committed 10 percent.
Then I was like,
no,
actually I think I can do this for the
pledge.
Um,
and then that meant I had this question
of,
well,
I'm planning to give awake,
come like million pounds over the course
of my life.
Where should that money go?
You know,
I want to make sure it has as big an
impact as possible.
And that meant I started digging into,
well how can we compare the between
different charities?
I found there was a ton of work for
them,
health and development economics that
could help us to answer this.
And what began as this kind of side
project between these two,
you know,
ivory tower,
academics,
me and toby,
we found that loads of people,
just Lee,
I'm taken by this idea both of giving
more but in particular have given more
effectively.
And over time,
this kind of global movement called
effective altruism start to form around
these ideas and sort to pollutant and a
couple of ways.
So one is the pollutant away from just
charitable donations to also thinking
about,
well,
what should I think about with respect
to make personal consumption?
What should I think about with respect
to my career if I'm really aiming to do
as much good as possible,
what should I do?
And then secondly also starting to think
about cause areas other than just global
poverty as well,
and it tends to be the case that within
the community at the moment,
the cause areas that people think are
the very most pressing our global health
and development still for sure.
But then also factory farming,
um,
where again,
there's just such a vast amount of
suffering which is completely
unnecessary.
And then also preservation the long,
long future of humanity and wedding
about risks of,
you know,
global catastrophe,
things that may be fairly unlikely but
would be very,
very bad.
Um,
if they did happen,
especially relating to new technology
like um,
you know,
novel pathogens,
sort of violence as you could design in
the lab and so on.
Well,
you're also very concerned with ai as
well,
right?
Artificial
intelligence.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
And that's,
I think in this category of,
if you look at the history of,
um,
human progress,
technological change just creates these
huge step changes and just how humanity
progresses.
So it was only 12 years,
um,
in 19 nine,
19,
33 to then 1945 between Leo Szilard
first coming up with the idea of the
nuclear chain reaction and that was just
purely conceptual idea in a bit of
paper,
12 years from that to then the
deployment of the first nuclear bomb and
think how radical a change that is
having suddenly being in the nuclear
age.
That was only 12 years.
Yeah.
We went over the,
the invention of the airplane to
dropping an atomic bomb out of the
airplane.
I believe it was 50 years,
right?
Somewhere in the neighborhood of 50
years.
Yeah.
Isn't that take a few?
So technological progress can suddenly
go in these huge leaps that we're not
prepared for the well often very not
prepared for.
And I think artificial intelligence is
in this context that you were,
were really making a radical progress in
ai,
especially over the last five years.
Um,
it's really one of the fastest
developing technologies,
I think,
and yet has huge potential and so many
different ways.
Um,
and as with any new technology,
huge positive potential relief,
you get ai light,
you can solve almost any problem,
but also potential risks as well.
Um,
where there's a risk that might be more
familiar.
Um,
you know,
what he's about automation,
unemployment and what he's about,
autonomous weapons,
which I think should be taken seriously.
And then also just what he's about.
Well,
what if we could really do manage to
make human level artificial
intelligence?
It's very good arguments that would then
quickly move to super human level,
artificial intelligence.
And what then are we now in a situation
like the neanderthals Homo Sapiens,
where we've suddenly created this
intelligence that's greater than our
own?
Are we able to control that?
Are we able to ensure that transition is
positive rather than negative?
Have you ever ever
considered the possibility when you look
at all the impoverished people in the
world,
all the cruelty,
all the people that we are so concerned
with,
material possessions and shallow
thinking and war and just the evil that
men do,
is it possible that we're sort of an
outdated concept that what we are as
these biological organisms that are
still slaves to the whole Darwinian
evolutionary survival of the fittest,
natural selection sort of paradigm that
we've operated under for all these many
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
years as humans?
Is it possible that we're giving birth
to the next thing that just like we
don't long for the days when we used to
be monkeys throwing shit at each other
from the trees.
One day we will be something different.
Whether it will be a combination of us
and these machines or whether we're
going to augment our own intelligence
with some sort of artificial.
Whether it's some sort of a an exo brain
or something that's going to take us to
the or.
It's going to be simply that we create
artificial intelligence.
Artificial intelligence no longer has
used for us because we're a logical and
then that becomes the new life form and
then we're,
we're locked hide in the cave somewhere
hoping the terminators don't get us.
Yeah,
I mean I think like over the longterm,
I mean with all of these things,
the question of kind of timelines is
very hot and sometimes people want to
project this discussion because Oh,
this is so far in the future.
Whereas I think like if something
sufficiently report we should be talking
about it even if maybe it's,
you know,
decades and generations hence might be
right.
I mean it might not be that far away,
but who knows,
Lakewood,
the atomic bomb.
That was hugely fast progress.
I'm just,
you know,
12 years.
So we want to be prepared.
Um,
but then has for like,
yeah,
is it going to be Homo sapiens around
for the next,
you know,
in a thousand years' time.
I think that would just be extremely
unlikely.
That will be around.
You think we're not going to be around
anymore.
Yeah,
I mean I think if intelligent creatures
are still around,
it's going to be some in a thousand
years' time,
it's going to be something that's not
homo sapiens.
Like he said this kind of fee.
Um,
oh.
It's like not what we would consider
consider kind of typical humans now.
Well,
we're obviously severely flawed.
Right?
And I mean,
if we're,
like,
if you ask people,
if you ask the average person,
do you think that in your lifetime you
can imagine a world without war?
Most people say no.
Like the vast majority of people say no
war,
a world without crime,
a world without violence,
a world without theft.
Most people say no.
That's,
that just shows you how inherently
flawed.
Most people view the human species.
We know that we can do it in small
groups.
You know,
like if the three of us were on an
island,
I'm pretty sure we wouldn't be stealing
from each other and murder each other,
right?
Yeah,
just a few of us.
But when you get to large scale,
humanity comes very easy to disassociate
or create this diffusion of
responsibility where there's enough
people.
So you don't really value them as much
and you're allowed to get away with some
pretty heinous stuff,
especially when you consider drone
warfare.
Things that we're able to do with long
distance where we're not seeing the
person that we're having the effect on.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's a very flawed thing.
The human species.
Um,
wouldn't it be better if something
better came along?
I mean,
I think this.
Yeah,
sorta.
Yeah.
I think that's the case though.
Well,
we'd be obsolete.
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
we're,
we're going to be obsolete in a hundred
years anyway.
I mean I'm,
as in will be dead.
Right?
So the question is just,
um,
we'll all kind of,
you know,
generations hence will,
it's not.
The question is not really about us,
it's about our grandchildren live.
It really forces the idea to be
considered like what is valuable about
life?
Like is it the experience,
is it happiness?
Is it shared fun?
Is it love?
Like what is,
what's valuable about being a person and
how much of that is going to change if
we're made out of something that people
have created or,
or maybe were made out of something
artificial intelligence has created
because we've created something that's
far superior to us.
So yeah,
I mean,
I have a view on this as you might
expect.
I mean,
in my view,
the thing that's valuable and the only
thing that's valuable ultimately as
conscious experience,
so that's good.
Like red conscious experiences,
happy happiness,
joy,
and so on.
That's positive,
that's good for the world of negative
conscious experiences,
suffering,
pain,
distress,
those are bad for the world.
And so that's why,
you know,
it's a good thing for me to do some
service to you to benefit you,
but I can't do anything good to benefit
this bottle of water.
Right?
And so then the key question in terms of
what should we think about,
supposing it is the case that,
you know,
thousand years time,
it's now a synthetic life.
It's artificial intelligence or
something that's a,
um,
the,
like the in charge and are no longer any
humans.
Would this be good or bad?
The question for me is,
you know,
are they having conscious experiences
and others conscious experiences,
good or bad?
So that's it.
Just conscious experience.
Yeah.
So it's a consumer so selfish.
It's a controversial view.
There's a thought experiment which is
often used to challenge this view.
Um,
do you want to hear that?
Yes.
So it's called the experienced machine
and the idea is supposing that tomato
you could plug into this machine,
it's like the most amazing vr you could
ever have.
And in this machine you will live,
let's say you live 200 years and you'll
be in the most amazing bliss.
You'll have the most amazing experiences
of,
you know,
and your experiences will involve
incredible relationships,
incredible creative achievement and so
on.
Um,
and it'll just be like the perfect life
that you could live expedientially for
the next 200 years.
And the question is in so far as
yourself interested,
so put aside considerations you might
have about wanting to make the world a
better place,
but just in so far as you care about
yourself,
would you plug into this thing?
Bearing in mind that in a certain sense
all of these experiences is going to be
fake.
You're going to have experiences of
having amazing friendships,
laying great works of art.
Can you think late works
of art and so on,
but they're.
They're not going to be available.
It's just sensory inputs provided by a
computer.
Right.
So the question is,
would you or you in so far as your self
interested and plug into this machine,
what would you,
what would you answer as a very good
question?
I might already be plugged into it,
right?
I mean you.
Oh,
so this is,
this is a great question and I think
it's a good argument against is the
question will supposedly you will
already plugged in.
Would you unplug?
Supposing I told you that actually
you're a banker in Monaco and fuck
Monaco,
I just,
I'm not interested in that.
No,
I want to stay right here.
Yeah.
So can I stay plugged in?
Please?
Do I have to pay more?
Would have to do.
You would have to do nothing,
but it's interesting man.
If people think so.
Most people,
and it seemed like maybe yourself would
intuitively you'd say,
no,
I wouldn't plug into this machine.
I don't know if I would say that I would
have to really deeply consider it
because right now it's just so.
It's so abstract.
This idea that that could be possible
and so it's.
It's fantasy.
We were having fun,
but when you talk to
the leading minds,
when it comes to virtual reality or
artificial reality or simulation theory,
you know when they start talking about
what will be possible one day they're
going to without a doubt within a 100
years or 500 years or whatever the
number is there going to be able to
create an artificial reality.
It's indiscernible from this reality.
You're going to be able to feel things.
There's going to be emotions that come
to you.
You're going,
they're going to be able to recreate
every single aspect of in everyday life.
It's just a matter of time.
I mean,
they're really close now and not.
Not really close in terms of like they
don't give you emotions and they don't
give you feeling,
but if you put on an htc vive and go
through some of those virtual reality
games,
I mean it's bizarre how real it feels.
And when you go back to like playing
pong,
did you ever play Polo?
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know,
it's such a weird thing that that
happened inside of me when I was a kid.
Pong came along,
we were blown away.
We couldn't believe that we could
actually do something on the television.
You could see it move.
It was so fantastic and if you gave that
to one of my kids,
they'd spit on it.
It'd be like,
what kind of pizza shit video game is
this.
Like they would think it's just so
ridiculous,
but to me at the time it was amazing.
You go from that to one of these htc
vive games which has all taken place
within my lifetime and you go,
well,
a lifetime from now.
If you follow the exponential increase
in the ability,
the technological innovation,
it's going to be spectacular.
It's going to be.
Absolutely.
So when that does happen,
how will you be able to know if it's
indiscernible how will you know if
you're in it and how do you know if
you're not in it right now?
That's the real question,
right?
Yeah.
I mean they'll actually some arguments
for thinking,
you know,
this is nick boss than my colleague of
mine simulation argument
for thinking we are and in late now,
in fact,
it's very likely that we should be.
Yeah.
I'm by that.
Um,
I actually,
I'm kind of agnostic.
I think you should take the,
the hypothesis seriously.
Um,
but I think the,
the argument doesn't quite go through
for what's attractive and what's not
attractive about that theory to you.
So his version of it.
Yeah.
So the argument is the frame and if you
could like his.
So his argument is the,
in the future,
supposing we believe that the human race
doesn't go extinct or post humans don't
go extinct over the next thousand,
few thousand years.
And secondly,
that the people in the future have an
interest in recreating their past just
for kind of historical interest of
learning that they're going to be
insistent running sync because then it
got now going to have huge,
amazing computer power.
They're going to be able to create
simulations of the past that,
um,
that to have some interest in running
simulations of the past.
Well,
the number of,
if that is true,
then the number of simulations that,
uh,
these future people are going to be
running will vastly outnumber the number
of actual timelines that kind of base
universes at work.
So for the one real universe where
history,
you're kind of unfolds,
there's also,
let's call it 10,000
simulations of that universe.
And if that's true,
then it's the case that well,
given that I'm just,
you know,
these things nearly all and dishonorable
for the people who are inside them is
overwhelmingly likely just in the base
plate that I'm going to be in a
simulation rather than I'm in the real
world.
And what Nick Bostrom says,
actually,
it's not that we definitely honest
simulation,
but he just points out the conflict
between these three kind of beliefs that
we seem to hold.
One is that we're not going to go
extinct in the near future too,
is that,
you know,
people in the future,
we'll have some interest in simulating
the past and thirdly that we're not
living in a simulation and he himself
gives,
you know,
a reasonable degree of belief.
Maybe he thinks it's like 10 percent,
15 percent likely that within a
simulation,
other people who understand the argument
very a bit more,
but I think,
you know,
it's something you should at least be
taken seriously.
Um,
the reason I object it is kind of,
um,
uh,
even weirder.
I think it's somewhat technical,
but the basic thought is just the,
um,
according to like the best guesses from
Cosmo monogenists,
we're actually in an infinite universe.
The Universe is infinitely big now.
We can't affect an infinitely big
universe were restricted by the speed of
light to what we can affect and to what
we can see.
Um,
but the best idea according to the best
thing that we have universities of keeps
on going,
but if so,
then there's old lady like an infinite
number of observers of people can have
in that bottom universe and that means
that you've now got kind of an infinite
number of people kind of experiencing
things and then you've got the
simulations and you've got like 10,000
simulations,
but you can't say there's 10,000
times as many simulated beings.
Is that our legal beings?
Because there's already an infinite
number of beings.
You're looking so good.
Uh,
constantly.
No,
no,
go ahead,
keep going.
But that means if you've got.
So the key of the,
um,
of Bostrom's argument was that you've
got 10,000
times as many simulated beings as you
have real like non simulated beings,
right?
The problem is,
is an infinite number of real beings
because the universe is infinite.
Yeah,
that's right.
And so if you've already got an infinite
number of real beings,
the fact that you've got 10,000
times infinite,
that's still infinite,
right?
You can't.
It's kind of a case where like our best
methods of assigning degrees of belief
to things kind of on out.
If you think it's,
you know,
there's an infinite number of simulated
beings and infinite number of real
beings.
Then what's the chance of you being one
of the other,
like we don't actually have the tools to
be able to answer that.
Neil degrasse Tyson was trying to
explain this to me a couple of weeks ago
that there are infinities that are
bigger than other infinities
yeah.
So that's also the case,
but yeah,
that was my roof,
my brain.
And so the number,
but the key,
we're all talking about the lowest was
called cardinality,
the smallest infinity,
which is the size of the infinity of all
the integers.
One,
two,
three,
four.
Counting numbers.
And if you take that size of infinity
and multiply it by 10,000,
let's say you just get the same number,
which is infinity,
right?
Um,
and then what Neil was saying was he had
to at least even bigger levels of
infinity.
So if you look at not just all the
counting numbers,
but all of the numbers,
you can make fractions out of a half a
quarter,
an eighth and so on.
That's a bigger.
That's just more numbers than the
infinity of the counting numbers.
I've spent a lot of time trying to
understand why human beings are so
obsessed with innovation,
why human beings are so obsessed with
technological progress.
And one of the things that I continued
to come to is that we think of
everything in this world as being
natural,
but the behavior of butterflies and
wolves and the way rivers run down from
the mountain.
But we don't think of ourselves and our
own behavior as natural.
We don't think of our own thirst for
conquest and innovation and and the even
materialism.
I think materialism is probably a very
natural reaction to our need to somehow
or another fuel innovation.
And that.
One of the ways to ensure that
innovation is constantly fueled is that
people are constantly obsessed with
buying new things,
constantly obsessed with the latest and
greatest which fuels innovation.
And when you look at the universe itself
and you look at all the various things
that we know to be natural processes in
the universe,
like tucked in order to make a human
being,
a star has to explode when you literally
are made out of Stardust,
which is when you run that by people for
the first time they go,
wait what?
Like in order to you for you to have
carbon based life form that has to be
created inside a burning,
dying star.
And that's the only way you make this
thing like what you are right now.
And then that thing makes artificial
reality.
And then that thing makes perhaps even
crazier.
Makes I mean if you follow the ideas of
technological progress,
if something gets to a point where it's
indiscernible from reality,
how do you know it's not a new reality?
How do you know it's not a new kind of
reality?
Like Jamie sent me hip to these
artificial worlds that people have
created online where there essentially
infinite and they're constantly changing
and morphing and growing.
And the Games are terrible.
People don't like them because you go go
to places and there's fucking nothing
there and you can go to an infinite
number of these places and there's
nothing there.
Like these adventures are nonexistent,
so you're on these.
You're in these gigantic fake worlds
where you're traveling from place to
place,
but right now we're looking at it in a
very two dimensional way.
You're looking at it on a flat screen
one day.
It's not going to be two dimensional.
One day it's going to be something that
you're interfacing with your
consciousness is interfacing with it.
Is it only real if we can take it and
drop it on something,
if we can hit it with a hammer,
if we could put it on a scale,
if we can use a measuring stick and
measuring,
is it only real there or is it real?
If it follows every single check,
like if you check off every single item
on the list of conscious reality and
conscious experience.
I think that's a great question because
I think the dichotomy that a lot of
people think in terms of natural and
unnatural,
I think it's just meaningless.
Um,
I mean,
people firstly think this is natural and
this is not,
I mean,
in a sense everything we're doing is
natural because we're like homosapiens a
part of a natural process and in
another,
maybe in another sense everything we're
doing is not natural.
But then why does that matter?
What's the model?
The relevance of something being natural
versus not natural.
Lots of stuff that happens in the
natural world is just really awful,
huge amounts of cannibalism.
They like,
um,
uh,
suffering,
so it's not clear why we would care
about something being natural,
natural.
Um,
but then the second question is,
yeah,
let's consider this a virtual reality
again,
um,
this experience machine that you could
plug yourself into.
And as part of the description I said,
oh,
none of this would be a real.
You'd have all of these interactions
with people that you think are friends
and so on,
but that wouldn't be avail.
And I think you could very well pushed
back on that and say why should
something be physically instantiated?
Like,
uh,
in order for it to count as a real
experience,
why is it not the case that in this
virtual reality,
your interacting with algorithms,
but that's just as much,
at least it's possible for that to be
just as much friendship as if you're
interacting with people who are flesh
and blood.
And I think it's hard to explain kind of
what the difference would be because you
know,
if you think about star trek,
usually quicker,
it can be friends with data and android
is not kind of bio biological,
but you know,
we think that,
uh,
you can still have kind of worth and
friendships and so on with creatures
that are not made of kind of human
biology,
in which case,
why is the fact that something merely
lives on silicone?
Why wouldn't.
That was kind of seemingly merely
software.
What does that mean?
You couldn't have kind of a genuine
friendship with that thing if it the.
If Actin is sufficiently sophisticated
way perhaps
isn't there also an issue with are
incredibly limited ability to view
reality itself because we're only
viewing the dimensions that are relevant
to us in this current state of carbon
based life form.
This curt,
this is talking monkey claim to the
spaceship flying through the universe.
This is,
this is what's important to us,
but when you pay attention to those
dudes who write on yellow legal pads and
they get into quantum physics and they
have all those crazy equations that
nobody but them understands,
maybe you do.
I look at that shit and I go,
what the fuck are they writing?
But they believe,
I mean,
what is the current model?
They,
they believe there's at least 11
dimensions that perhaps could be more.
What if there is a dimension that you
can plug into that it's purely
consciousness driven,
meaning there's no physical experience.
There's no touching the ground.
There's no gravity,
but you exist in a conscious state and
it's perpetual.
Like if you take a rocket ship and it
gets past our gravity and shoots off
into distance space and you have a clear
shot of,
you know,
14 billion years back to the beginning
of the universe itself with nothing in
the way,
you're just going to keep going for $14,
billion light years,
you're just going to keep going.
Like,
what if there is a place that your
consciousness can go to like that where
it can't,
it's no longer burdened by biology,
by the timeline of birth to death,
by the limitations of the flesh.
But consciousness itself can exist in
some bizarre dimension that we just have
an access to.
So,
yeah,
I mean,
I think consciousness is probably just
ultimately a physical process.
Why do you think that in a ultimately
[inaudible] of a conservation of energy?
Um,
the reason being so,
you know,
this is age,
old philosophical debate between,
um,
the motorists and lists people who think
is consciousness just ultimately some
sort of physical process or is it
something special?
So descartes thought there was this,
um,
old grant gland.
There's a little bit of your brain and
your conscious kind of soul was just
going to steering your,
like monkey body free with this pineal
gland.
But the question is just for why I think
the strongest argument about why that
couldn't be right is it seems to be like
it would have to be creating energy out
of nowhere and we've never.
There seems to be just fixed law of the
universe that just can't happen because
in order for,
you know,
this conscious mind to,
if it's not merely a physical process,
if it's not just the brain,
in order for that to be able to effect
what this physical entity is doing,
it would have to use energy to be able
to do that.
So the energy would have to be coming
from somewhere and if it's not coming
from just the physical realm,
then suddenly we've got this counter
examples to all the rest of science
sort of.
But you aware of the theories of human
neurotransmitters being pathways to
other dimensions,
like dimethyltryptamine didn't know
about all that.
Um,
I mean,
I know about the empty.
Do you know what it's produced in the
pineal gland where descartes thought
that all that stuff was going on the
seat of the soul with the Egyptians
called the eye of horus.
The reason why the Catholics and so many
ancient religions were so focused on
pine cones and their,
their art and their,
their imagery.
That's the pineal gland.
That's the image of it.
That's what it's supposed to represent.
And for people who've had these intense,
transformative psychedelic experiences
by consuming exogenous
dimethyltryptamine,
which is produced by the brain that you
have these insane,
transformative experiences where you
feel like you are traveling to other
dimensions.
Yeah.
So I think,
I mean,
I do want to say like,
have you done any of that?
Um,
I've never done DMT,
son of eventual not what are you doing?
You're wasting your time.
I know that's a good way,
but,
but it's something that's in the brain.
I mean,
it's a natural product of a human
biology.
I mean,
whether it's natural or not isn't the
question just,
uh,
you know,
if I'm going to have a career based on
my brain,
I want to be very careful to,
to not break it,
to not be okay.
Yeah.
But it's one of the most transient drugs
ever observed in the body.
Your body brings it back to baseline in
like 15 minutes.
Hmm.
Okay.
Is that,
um,
because I mean,
there's a lot of.
I do think there's like tons of people
very often,
greatly overestimate the risks of
nonlegal blogs,
like mdms like super safe and so on.
Very overestimate the list,
the risks that you're saying.
Yeah.
That's the MTMA yeah.
Is Weird,
right?
That's a weird one.
It's not a natural drug.
Dimethyltryptamine.
I think the real concern would be
psychological because what you face
is so bizarre.
Terence Mckenna Mckenna had the best
quote about it.
I think he said that,
uh,
you would risk death by astonishment.
Yeah.
Okay.
So their thing.
Well,
it's a,
it's so bizarre that it's almost a sin
for a guy as smart as you did not
experience it,
but will you just come right back and
you're,
even when you're there,
you're there mean to you.
It's not like you,
your consciousness dissolves into some
bizarre quasi living state and then you
have to like work your way back to being
you again.
Now you're,
you.
You're will macaskill in the dimension,
whatever the fuck it is.
But what's crazy about it is that this
is produced in the very area where
descartes was believing the seat of the
soul is in so many different eastern
religions and all,
all this psychological,
like all these different,
all these different religions and all
these different cultures,
they were all convinced at that one
gland had some massive significance in
terms of the spirit and the soul,
whatever that means.
Whatever spirit means.
So yeah.
So then the question is just in these
experiences,
is it the case that you'll like seeing
into genuinely seeing into another
dimension,
or is it the case that just have a new
kind of perspective on consciousness?
So one thing I do think is that in terms
of conscious experience,
this the sort of conscious experiences
that humans have access to,
and I think that must just be point
zero,
one percent of the entire landscape of
possible conscious experiences.
So if you think,
imagine if you have a bat and you could
echo locate,
that's just a radically different
conscious experience.
I don't think that maps on to any sort
of conscious experience that humans
could have.
Have you seen people do that?
Blind people can do that.
It's pretty amazing.
That is amazing.
Very effectively too.
It's like shockingly effectively.
Yeah,
I think you're absolutely right.
I mean,
but there's also experiences,
human experiences that are available
without drugs that some people have
achieved through radical states of
meditation and Kundalini Yoga where they
could achieve natural psychedelic
states,
holotropic breathing,
people that have done that.
I've experienced like really radical
psychological transformations and
incredible psychedelic experiences from
that as well.
Yeah.
And so I think like,
um,
these sorts of experiences are very
important,
very interesting.
Um,
and what they,
you know,
I said that maybe we experienced this
point zero,
one percent of all possible conscious
experiences and that just allows you to
do like see a little bit more of this
potential vast landscape.
Uh,
well as I think,
but I think there's nothing on magical
about saying ultimately that's all
explained in terms of physics in terms
of um,
different sorts of neurons firing and
differences once have a transmit as and
so on.
We don't need to say,
oh,
and it's also this other thing which
breaks all the known laws of physics
that you're seeing into some other
dimension.
In order for that to be an incredibly
important thing.
I'm a as unscientific to say we know
almost nothing about consciousness in
terms of the areas of scientific
inquiry.
We have no understanding at all about
the relationship between conscious
experiences and um,
you know,
what we would think of as physical
processes.
We really have no idea about,
you know,
if you take,
give me any sufficiently complicated
physical processes,
which,
uh,
which are conscious and which are not
all we can go on is really,
that's what I'm conscious.
And so I know the things that kind of
liked me or probably conscious too and
that's the best we've got really.
Um,
and this is known as a hard problem of
consciousness and force.
It was often say they've solved it with
something and I think it's always
begging the question.
I think we should be very open to the
fact that I'm just as in um,
you know,
3000 BC people had no idea about the
laws of physics.
This was just completely unexplored
territory.
We should think contemporary science,
this is just a big,
like a big black gap in our scientific
understanding.
And perhaps it's something maybe 21st
century science,
maybe 22nd century science can really
get to grips with.
Yeah.
It does seem like the ultimate question,
like what is it for,
why is it here?
What controls it?
Is it in the mind?
Is it external?
Is the brain just to an antenna that
tunes into consciousness?
The dimethyltryptamine question is so
bizarre because it's the most potent
psychedelic drug known to man and your
brain man.
Except for I didn't know if this is a
myth I've heard.
It's what gets made when you die.
Yeah.
The third,
they believe that during high rates of
stress where your body believes you're
going to die and when your dreaming,
when you're in heavy rem sleep,
your body produces larger amounts of it
than,
than baseline.
But they don't know.
It's,
it's really difficult.
They've only just now within the last
few years,
the Cottonwood Research Foundation,
which,
uh,
Dr Rick Strassman has a big part of it.
He's the guy who wrote the book Dmt,
the spirit molecule.
He did a bunch of the first FDA approved
drug trials with civilians where they
took people and they gave them a
schedule,
one drug dimethyltryptamine,
which is so crazy that it's a schedule
one drug that your body produces,
but they gave it to be bull
intravenously over the course of several
months.
And they documented all the different
trips and all the different.
Um,
the different commonalities that these
people had in their experiences and he's
working very closely with the cottonwood
research foundation and one of the
things that they found is that they've
recently discovered it was just
anecdotal evidence that it was produced
by the pineal gland.
We knew the DMT was produced by the
liver and the lungs,
but now they know for sure because
they've isolated it in rats.
So in living rats,
they know that they produce dmt with the
gland.
So that,
that explains a lot of,
you know,
ancient eastern mysticism and all the
symbology this holy symbols that people
had to represent this gland.
Now they know,
okay,
well this is definitely does produce
this incredibly potent psychedelic drug.
But now the cross,
the question is at what levels during
what periods of stress,
like how do you have to bring someone to
the point of death before they
experienced this?
And if that is the case,
is it possible that consciousness itself
is something that we,
you know,
since we haven't really figured out what
exactly it is,
is it possible that consciousness can
travel through this chemical pathway
that maybe these intense
dimethyltryptamine experiences are in
fact a gateway to what people have
assumed exists from the beginning of
time,
like an afterlife or a sea of souls or
something,
some,
some stage of existence other than this
physical existence that we all
experience right now.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I feel like I'd be crazy talk,
right?
It's as big they see
coming out of my mouth.
I'm going,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Dude?
I mean I think I just be suppliers of
consciousness was just this one
chemical.
I think it's much more likely that
something is this emergent phenomena
from this incredibly complex system of,
you know,
billions of different neurons filing in
a certain way and when you have a
certain process that sufficiently
complex in the right way somehow,
and this is just this big black box that
we've got no idea about,
somehow subjective experience comes out
of that.
But it would seem,
I mean otherwise the issue is you could
have just dmt to traveling and just a
test tube or something and petri dish
and it would seem like,
oh,
is this petri dish?
I'm conscious that would seem the least
lane.
Why would that be the case?
If you're breathing air and you're,
you know,
the air keeps you alive,
like you're breathing in and breathing
that you don't think that air carries
the life with it to another place.
Right.
Era is just a component of life.
It's something that your body requires.
Yeah.
So I mean it's possible.
Maybe it's the case though.
Again,
I feel I'd be surprised if it was like
this chemical is necessary for
consciousness and stuff.
I'm not saying that's necessarily,
but what I am curious as to how
consciousness varies.
Consciousness,
consciousness and the actual feeling of
being alive varies depending upon your
health.
Depending behind stress levels,
depending upon love and happiness and
all these different factors change the
way you view the world,
which is really interesting because in
in effect that change is consciousness
and you can be more.
You know,
you can be more elevated,
like you can guarantee you all of this
effect of altruism that you're
concentrating on is somehow another
elevating your consciousness because
you're putting out so much love and so
much happiness and you are helping so
many people.
There's so many positive benefits to
your very existence.
I've got to manage,
I've got to believe rather than somehow
or another that manages to come back to
you.
I,
it definitely comes back
to me in kind of how I feel about my
life.
I mean,
when we were talking about how,
uh,
you know,
money is just not the key to a happy
life.
The question is,
well,
what is,
and the answers are having a great
community,
um,
having a greater purpose in life,
feeling like you're making a difference.
So all of these reasons of why.
So we've built up this kind of community
around effective altruism.
Um,
you know,
people all around the world who are
making a significant change.
So for example,
donating 10 percent of the income to the
charities they think are most effective
or pursuing a career that we think is
really effective.
And one thing I wasn't surprising from
the outset,
but I'm so happy happened is that
there's a strong community is formed.
It's kind of like a little global
village or something and people have
found the actually far from being a
sacrifice as you might have expected,
was actually incredibly rewarding
because you've now got this community of
people who have shared aims to you and
you're all working towards this greater
goal.
And that's something that I think is
very lacking in the world today.
So many people just,
they work nine to five and you know,
they have a nice time on the weekends,
but they're like,
where there's all of this going and at
the end of my life am I really going to
think,
yeah,
I made the most of this.
Whereas if you think at the end of your
life like,
Yup,
I dedicated my life to helping others
and I had this transformative impact on
thousands of people,
you're not going to think at the end of
your life,
Gee,
I really wasted that.
It's just something I don't think you
can really look at.
If you go deep though down the
philosophical rabbit hole and you really
consider that life is this temporary
experience and even benefiting someone
through this temporary experience is
still a temporary experience.
It's like you are helping somebody gave
them a pillow for the ride and it's a
temporary ride and the ride comes to an
end and then what?
And then what is the point of all this
like what is the point of effective
altruism if you're just helping people
during this temporary ride,
it doesn't seem to
mean anything.
Yeah.
So I think there's two things.
Um,
I like it.
I have loads.
I can do that too.
Just raise up.
I just go with the.
It was freak myself out.
Well,
we do get freaked out at this,
you know,
when you think of cosmic is essential
and so thanks to existence.
So I think there's two.
I think it was two emphasis yet.
Okay.
The first is that the light is the goal.
Ultimately,
again,
if you think the purpose of life is to
increase the amount of happiness and the
juice,
the amount of suffering,
the final goal is good experiences and
the kind of anti goal is bad
experiences.
So when we're sitting here talking,
having a great time,
this is us kind of achieving getting
points in the wind.
I'm counter so we're having to just
time.
That's like,
yeah,
if we were really hating this then we'd
be losing.
Well even more so because we're
broadcasting this live and millions of
people are gonna hear it and hopefully
not having hopefully that enjoying it.
Hopefully,
and maybe if they're not at least a
little stress relief,
like maybe they're at the gym and I go,
these fucking idiots when they're doing
squats and they're getting angry.
Yeah,
so I think that's the first thing,
but then the second thing is I'm late to
this idea of cosmic significance where
Juan often motivate.
So you say,
Oh,
well we're just along for the ride.
We're all going to get eaten up by the
sun eventually and so on.
What's the calculator?
Purpose of life by actually think what
are some ways that our actions now can
have much greater cosmic significance
and that's if that's because I think if
you think that the human race survives
for the next few centuries,
it seems kind of inevitable that we're
going to spend to the stars.
Um,
and I think that would be good.
Again,
from this perspective,
we can go into more arguments if you
want,
of just saying what we want to do is
promote happiness and reduce suffering.
If that means we can live on other
planets as well and have kind of fiving
civilizations there.
Not only were the people are having
great lives but also making scientific
artistic contributions and so on,
then that's a good thing to do as well.
Well,
there's no technological reason for
thinking that we won't be able to do
that in the future.
I'm given current late to technological
progress unless something really bad
happens along the way,
and this kind of gets back to one of the
things we talked about right at the
start was one of the focus areas of the
effective altruism community is on
turnover.
Juice risks from,
of human extinction,
of global catastrophic risks.
These are the sorts of things that could
imperil the human journey as it were.
Um,
and I think if you're working to
mitigate some of these things,
then you're increasing the chance that
we do get to the sort of level where,
um,
he,
yeah,
humanity can have a five in the future,
not just on this planet but on other
planets as well.
And that actually means your actions
really do have this huge cosmic
significance.
So the conscious effort to be
kind,
person,
a generous person and effective altruism
spreads and it impacts people.
There's this ripple effect and your good
deeds could perhaps fuel enough people
with this thought and with effective
altruism and more people might act on
that to the point where we reduced the
amount of suffering to the point where
we extend the lifespan of human beings.
We extend the areas where we have no
war.
We reduced the amount of violence to the
point where we can successfully innovate
to the point where we can get off this
planet.
That's that.
And then start from scratch with a new
dictator on Mars,
Donald Trump on Mars.
How about that?
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
so I think the boat,
none.
Mars will become president of Mas.
I'd be pretty happy with that.
Be Fascinating if we'd have to go to war
with Maurice.
Yeah.
Do you think though the.
I mean I've wondered about this many,
many times.
I wonder if it's an outdated idea,
this idea of traveling to the stars.
And again,
I go back to this whole inter
dimensional thing that I wonder if
that's the reason why we have never been
visited by other planets,
by species from another planet.
Maybe that's not what happens.
Maybe they develop artificial realities.
Maybe like Jamie was talking about to me
with these artificial computer
realities.
Like if,
if someone develops some sort of a
matrix like world where you can plug
into an experience and an infinite
number of things in an infinite number
of artificially created dimensions that
are indistinguishable from this,
why would you want to like risk a six
month trip and a metal tube to another
planet?
I mean maybe that's really retro.
Maybe that's a really ancient way of
looking at things.
Maybe it's like Zepplins,
like big flying balloons instead of,
you know,
so yeah,
the question you raised is called the
Fermi paradox,
which is just given this.
So 100 billion stars in our galaxy,
m 8 billion galaxies in the effect
double universe,
100 billion in the observable universe.
Uh,
the nfs is also the old 15 billion years
old.
So if it was the case that life is very
common that it's very easy for us to,
um,
life to then developed a level of
advanced technological ability.
We should expect to see evidence of
aliens all over the Bronx.
But yet we see absolutely none.
And that means that from somewhere from
a habitable planet,
somewhere along the path from habitable
planet to um,
you kind of space fanning civilization,
there must be some big filter.
There must be some step that's just
incredibly hard for that to have it.
And can I be unlikely that civilization
musome or life moves from that step to
another.
And one hypothesis is this,
yeah,
like people just society.
Civilization gets to sufficiently
advanced level and they just chill out.
They just go internally.
Yeah.
They go and tunnel.
The issue with that explanation I think
is it's just not long enough because,
you know,
you'd have to think that that's for this
kind of filter to work has to be able to
really filter.
Filter.
Yeah.
As in like,
because there's so many stars,
so many earth,
so many seemingly habitable planets.
Um,
it has to be the case that it's
exceptionally unlikely at some stage of
other like,
and not just really unlikely as in like,
you know,
one in a trillion,
unlikely to,
on this path for them,
habitable planet to space fading
civilization.
And so you'd have to think of a trillion
civilizations that get to this level of
technological ability,
the old shoes to turn inward.
And that seems very unlikely.
It seems like,
well,
at least one word really spread out.
And if so,
then we'd see evidence of that.
Um,
because cosmically speaking the time for
them,
I'm getting to the level of
technological capability where you can
spend to the stars and the level where
we'd be able to get to see real evidence
of that is kind of small.
So I actually think that the reason that
we can't see aliens is because the very
first stages of life and incredibly
unlikely the move from nothing to kind
of basic application.
And then secondly to move from single
celled organisms to multicellular
organisms.
And the reason for thinking this is very
unlikely is it took an incredibly long
time.
I'm on earth billions of years before
this happened and in particular in the
move from single cell to multi-celled
life,
that's only ever happened once.
And so given that we don't see any
aliens,
we should think some part of this is
really hard.
Our best guess is that,
that,
that move them single cell to
multi-celled and perhaps from the
creation of the first cells as well,
that was incredibly difficult.
Um,
and that means that we're just
exceptionally lucky to be alive as it
were.
But
if the universe is infinite,
that means that this has happened in
infinite number of times.
That's what I though it might be very
far away.
Probably like sufficiently far the way
that we are not connectable to eat.
Like we can't contact each other,
observe each other.
But there's an infinite number of those
infinitely far places.
Yes,
there will be some.
There will be some like clusters of the
universe and again,
the idea that the universe is infinite.
Certainly a hypothesis,
and I'm just deferring to other people
who say it's the leading.
Well,
the most puzzling hypothesis to me was
the evidence of supermassive black holes
being at the center of every galaxy and
that the hypothesis was that the
supermassive black holes are exactly one
half of one percent of the mass,
the entire galaxy.
And then if you go through those
supermassive black holes,
you may in fact go into a completely new
universe filled with hundreds of
billions of galaxies,
each with supermassive black holes at
the center of those galaxies,
which will take you to hundreds of
billions of galaxies in another
universe.
And that it's never ending.
And that's what the real infinity is.
It's not just the mass of all the things
that we can observe in the 14 plus
billion light years that we know of from
the Big Bang to today.
It's all of those things being portals
to incredibly different.
Totally new universes.
Okay.
So it's turtles all the way down.
Turtles all the way down.
So the.
The real question to me,
and this I had,
I proposed this to Brian Cox,
I didn't get a sufficient answer.
It's why would we assume that there's
someone more advanced than us?
Like it is possible that someone,
some species,
some thing is the tip of the spear that
some thing is the first,
that something is the most advanced life
form in the universe.
Why would we assume that someone would
be more advanced than us?
If we are the most advanced thing that
we can find?
The only logic that I could point to was
that,
that we're relatively young in terms of
the history and the age of the universe
itself.
The university itself being roughly 14
billion years old.
We are four point six.
What do we.
What is the age of the earth?
Somewhere,
somewhere in there,
somewhere in the neighborhood,
right.
Relatively young.
When you consider that 10 billion years
of life give or take happen or,
or existence happened before we came
along,
why would we assume that there's
anything out there that's more advanced
and why would we assume that this isn't
as far as anybody's ever gotten?
I mean,
that's so in terms of infinity,
right?
Fourteen billion years seems like a long
time,
but in terms of infinity,
it's a blink.
So I think we should believe that in
the.
And again,
let's now just fits the infinity and
just think about the observable
universe,
which is finite because people pulled
over sweating in their car right now.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
Infinity.
Have you ever heard of claims number?
This is not a total digression of claims
number.
I don't believe so.
It was known as um,
uh,
the largest number ever.
Seriously used in the mathematical proof
and the table and of wait.
But why has this amazing post?
I'm trying to explain just how big could
I am's number.
It is.
And I think you have to use a special
notation and what's to be able to
explain it.
The numbers just get really big and once
you really start to think this through,
you're just like your left,
just kind of rocking back and forth.
Um,
yeah.
No,
like just peeked out.
Yeah.
For the little monkey,
Lillian is so big affiliate.
It's just a speck of dust compared to
even a trillion years,
a speck of dust.
When you consider the possibility of the
universe itself being infinite or the
possibility that is a continuous cycle
of big bangs to expansion,
to contraction back to an infinitely
small point,
back to another big bang,
which is a plausible possibility.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think,
yeah.
I'm also,
I'm fairly.
Well,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not neil degrasse Tyson,
a butch thing,
tons of the science.
I think my understanding of the moment
is that we currently think that the
universe is just expanding and it just
keeps expanding.
I know it's definitely a leading theory
that it was going to expand and slow and
then kind of on.
Yes.
Um,
but you mentioned a humans being the
most advanced kind of cliche.
I think that probably is correct in the
observable or certainly our galaxy,
let's say in our.
Well we know it is in our solar system,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
But I think we know it isn't our galaxy
as well.
I think so.
And again the nice so far.
But the thing is that,
um,
it's far as in it's like 100,000
light years thinking about,
but when you're thinking about 15
billion years of age of the universe,
that's actually just a very short period
of time.
But why would you assume that 100,000
light years from now there is not
something exactly like us.
So it's possible.
But the thing is that if it was somewhat
easy or if it was just not incredibly
difficult for intelligent life to
evolve,
then it would have happened in the past
already and we will see evidence of it
and the fact that we don't see any
evidence at all of intelligent life and
other solar systems or,
and like a toll a suggest.
It's incredibly difficult for that to
happen.
But isn't that like being in the woods
and unzipping your tent and sticking
your head out and saying,
I don't see anything.
This must be empty woods.
Um,
it's more like,
I mean,
you're talking about a very small area
that you've observed and we've taken
account of.
So I think it's more like,
um,
because I think
if an alien civilization or us in the
future goes to kind of start,
um,
uh,
yeah,
spending to the stars in the course of,
you know,
uh,
just a few seconds,
million years,
let's say there'll be nearly significant
evidence you'd see dyson's spheres being
constructed around sons,
you know,
to harness the sun's energy.
You'd see some evidence of like
dialectic engineering projects and so
on.
It'd be like a really big impact.
You'd see that with hundreds of
thousands of light years between us and
the observable objects,
again,
100,000
light years is just not very long.
Um,
compared to the kind of 15 billion.
So it would just be this amazing
coincidence if it's the case that he,
a life that's as advanced and more
advanced than us has a voltage,
just the same time as us were 100,000
years,
give or take is basically just the same
time but hasn't evolved in the past,
hasn't involved more than a million
years ago where we will start to see
kind of major impact of that.
So if something within the observable
universe we've observed so little,
we don't even have really adequate
photographs of anything outside of our
solar system.
I mean everything is just radio
spectrum,
you know,
these,
the analysis is that they're getting off
of light waves of what the components of
the atmosphere is.
And so using your analogy,
what I'm suggesting is that,
um,
if it was the case that alien life was
not intelligent,
life was not that hard to come by.
You'd stick your head out of the 10 and
you look like Tokyo.
I've often looking like the woods.
Why does it have to look like Tokyo?
Why can't it look like Kansas?
Why can't I be like really spread out?
And very little life because I think if
life is splitting out,
then it's just going to want to,
what does life do?
It just phase to harness resources in
place to color more of itself.
And maybe it reaches a point where it
realizes that's few tile just
concentrates on effective altruism at
home.
Oh battlestar.
So that's the turning inward suggestion
again.
And so maybe it's the case that like,
yeah,
like is it more important to get your
shit together at home or to go all over
the world with the same bullshit ideas,
right?
I mean that's the case would not be the
same thing that you could turn towards
interstellar travel.
Like wouldn't it be more important for
these communities to concentrate on
taking care of their planet and figuring
out a way to work in some sort of a
harmonious fashion with the very nature
of the planet itself rather than travel
to the star.
I mean possibly,
but now imagine this.
So on this alien alien planet,
there's 10 billion aliens and they're
like,
let's say that a thousand years more
advanced than humans at the moment.
Uh,
in order for this argument to work,
it'd have to be the case that every
single one of them makes that decision
to just turn inwards and focus on why
was that
the case because not all those people
would be the ones that would innovate in
the first place.
It wouldn't have to be everyone that
makes a decision,
but have to be everyone have a high
enough consciousness to figure out how
to make these interstellar machines
decides not to harness this nuclear
power and jet off into space.
But I think over time that will just,
that would just be everyone because.
Well,
yeah,
I mean just technological progress just
keeps going.
And eventually like tech.
I mean obviously we're doing this like
weird though,
experiment speculating on economics and
sociology of um,
hypothetical alien world.
But,
uh,
I mean just at some point as that,
as a civilization progresses,
then,
um,
there's gonna be many,
many actors.
I'm with sufficient power.
So it's sort of liability to spend to
the stars.
You need to say that every single one of
them decides to turn inwards.
So it's sort of like,
um,
technology becomes very rare and then
ultimately over time becomes very common
like the cell phone cell phone.
Right.
So when cell phone was first invented,
it was extremely rare and very
expensive.
Now everyone has one and the
capabilities of those cell phones have
greatly,
greatly improved and that this will
happen with everything including space
travel.
Yeah.
But also it doesn't need to be the case
that gets up to 10 billion people.
Even if it's just like a thousand people
or something.
Again,
it would just seem unlikely that,
you know,
in every civilization and every one just
has,
you know,
even just a thousand people,
everyone chooses not a single person
thinks,
hey,
I would just want that to be more like
spread out.
Now that obviously is dependent upon
there being a more advanced civilization
than human beings on the planet earth.
Because if there weren't,
if there were a few years behind us,
like if they're stuck in the 19 fifties
or maybe they're stuck in ancient Greece
or you know,
then then obviously they don't have the
capabilities yet.
We might be the very most advanced,
we might be the very tip of the spear.
Right?
Yeah,
and I just think,
yeah,
because I think it would be unlikely
that
something more advanced happened just a
little bit faster than us,
but not say 100 million years ago,
which is not very long ago.
Right.
In cosmic terms,
but it's still possible.
I mean it's still possible that
something happened a hundred years
quicker than us or that they haven't had
the same setbacks that we've had in
terms of asteroidal impacts and natural
catastrophe supervolcanoes and the link.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a real weird thought experiment
because you start thinking,
you start extrapolating,
okay,
well where are we going to be?
You know,
where are we going to be in,
why would we do that?
Like that's one of the things that
always gets me about this whole trip to
Mars and I had a joke about it in my,
of my last comedy special where people,
where somebody actually said this to me
because it was before California.
It's solved it's drought or Mother
Nature solved our drought for us rather.
Or people like,
hey man,
we should really consider going to Mars
because mean look at our environment and
California is almost out of water.
And my joke was like,
we're right next to the fucking ocean.
Like there's so much water.
You can see the end of it.
We have a salt problem.
We don't have a water problem.
Like what are you going to do?
You going to bring water to Mars?
Like that's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard in my life.
Yeah.
This,
this weird.
When people start talking about.
I mean I think so there's the,
it's going to Mas St Newton laws saying
in McCone right now,
like the aim of doing that because it's
awesome.
Totally on board with that the same way
as like going to the moon.
It's like look what we can achieve.
This is an exciting like global human
fluidic totally just the space shuttle
going into orbit.
It's pretty bad ass,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
But then this talk of like,
oh well we need this and what's to be
able to survive as a species.
I'm like,
look,
if you want to have this kind of refuge
or colony in order to make the math more
robust,
Mazda is just not a great place to pick.
There's so many different ways that,
um,
I mean Mazda's like wally and
inhospitable and if you wanted to build
a refuge,
why not go into the sea?
Um,
that's like a going to be protected
from,
um,
you know,
Viola says or asteroid impacts.
And so really though,
if one of those big things that slammed
into the Yucatan slams into where your
villages and the sea,
I mean,
if you,
if you had,
um,
this underwater village with 10 years of
food supplies and so on,
then you could like come back because
the impact from the asteroid wasn't just
like shook everyone office that the sky
is falling,
the sky is get clouded over with earth
rang for a million years.
Oh,
what is that as nla impact.
Yeah.
That's so interesting.
That's so insane.
When you think about how big that thing
was that killed the dinosaurs 65 million
years ago and that there's hundreds of
thousands of those things floating
around in space.
So yeah,
I was asking some people at Nasa just,
um,
uh,
just two days ago actually on how many
of them we've managed to identify
because their cvs about kind of scanning
the skies to find them all.
Um,
and the answer,
I thought we had it covered.
I thought this was something that Nasa
was like,
yeah,
we know with all the like.
And they have response was like,
no,
we've got no idea.
We just,
we don't know how many of them then.
And so we don't know how many we've
managed to track.
There's a guy named Randall Carlson and
I found on podcast a few times and he's
obsessed with the idea that asteroidal
impacts were probably would have ended
the ice age,
you know,
10 to 12,000
years ago.
And,
and he,
there's a significant amount of physical
evidence that points to this,
um,
both in,
evidence of impact and nuclear glass.
Try think it's called tribe tonight.
I forget the exact word,
but it,
it appears all throughout Europe and
Asia and around that same timeline,
around 10,000
and 12,000
years ago when they do core samples and
it points to this idea that there were
significant impacts from asteroidal
objects all over Europe and all over
Asia around that time.
And they think some of them slammed into
the ice caps that were,
you know,
North America was covered in a giant
chunk of it was covered in as much as
two miles high of ice just 10,000
years ago.
And he points to an incredible amount of
physical change in the environment that
looks like it took place over a very
short period of time.
Like catastrophic change over incredibly
short amount of time that he believes
points to these impacts.
Melting the ice caps,
creating massive amount of flooding,
killing off.
Who knows how many people resetting
civilization in many different parts of
the world.
And this evidence of these,
uh,
of the nuclear glass of these micro
diamonds that also exist.
They find them during a nuclear test
sites when they blow off bombs and they
also find them at asteroidal impacts
sites and you know,
when,
you know that we have been hit many
times in the past and they do have
evidence of that and then you see the
moon and all the different impact
craters on the moon.
He know that this is just what he calls
a cosmic shooting gallery essentially.
He's like,
it's very likely that that was the cause
of the end of the ice age.
There's a lot of,
there's climate data that sort of seems
to point to that as well.
Okay.
So this,
so this is now like really outside my
area of expertise
and you some links to some of his stuff
because he's been obsessed with this for
about 30 years because fascinating guy.
The two things that would really
surprise me about that.
Firstly,
just that there were so many ice ages
and it was just seemed to be this.
It comes on and goes off for sure.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
fairly dynamic,
predictable process where there's
asteroid impact.
Super Random.
So you wouldn't expect to have this kind
of back and forth then I make,
if it was asteroids that was doing it.
And then secondly,
my understanding would be the asteroids
would cool the planet because asteroid
hits,
ash just spreads out all over the sky
that just blocks out sunlight.
So it would surprise me if it had this
kind of warming effect.
Well,
I think the idea is that first of all,
when it it,
the impact is massive and it melts off
just to the huge chunk of the amount of
water that is a covering North America.
Right?
And that's one of the things that causes
this massive flooding and this massive
changing of the topography and as far as
like what causes the net,
I don't know if it interrupts it
temporarily and then it comes back and
gets warmer.
But the,
uh,
that natural cycle of warming and
cooling has been going on since they
mean from as far back as they can
measure it.
What he's talking about.
His significant quick changes.
Also,
the extinction event that killed
somewhere around 65 percent or more of
all of the large mammals in North
America,
really quickly,
like bully mammoths really quickly.
Saber Tooth Tigers,
they don't know about that.
That's,
there's a lot of speculation back and
forth about that because they would
think that humans did it.
But then they found these mass dead
sites where they're not consumed.
And uh,
this was the ones that he showed where
these woolly mammoths,
they found them where they had their
legs were broken and it looked like they
just,
the impact of something had knocked them
flat and they'd found like thousands of
them and these mass death side sites.
But I thought that the,
um,
so firstly it just seemed to me like the
homo,
the idea that humans killing them all
just seems like crazy.
Oh No,
I thought it just seems like such a good
explanation.
They didn't even have.
They had atlatl so,
but then I was like,
the best weapon they have at the time.
They weren't even riding on horseback at
the time.
But then with respect to the death
sites,
I thought the mechanism for killing a
woolly mammoth,
you just got like 200 humans and you
just chase the William mammoth,
a cliff.
So that does work if you can get them
near a cliff.
But the idea of getting them all near
cliffs and killing them all off by a
bunch of people that hadn't figured out
the wheel seems a little unlikely.
It's possible like over thousands of
years because that's the thing.
Like we often tell these stories about,
um,
you know,
these civilizations,
humans,
it's like,
oh,
and then they might relate to me,
this journey to your left and so on.
And often that's like they moved a mile
of the uh,
so it's like fate journeys actually just
this very gradual.
And certainly if you've got this grave
site and it's got well,
hundreds of woolly mammoths in this one
place,
that might be over thousands of years.
I mean,
again,
this is just something I know that's the
thing.
They're talking about carbon dating,
that they're all,
it's all within the same time period.
You'd have to really go over his stuff
with a fine tooth comb and talked to him
about it because I'm not the right guy.
I just,
I just listened to them and go woo,
and then try to relate it as much as
possible.
There's a podcast that I actually read
tweeted today because somebody brought
it up on Youtube.
It's available,
so I'll,
I'll send you to it afterwards and see
if you.
What do you think about it?
But.
But this is something.
Yeah,
but if you know the book Sapiens,
one of them,
you're like the fifth person to talk
about it.
I've got to get everyone talks about
savings savings is the book that
wouldn't just pull it up a little closer
to you because it makes a big difference
in the sound,
but yeah,
one of the things that most blew my mind
there was,
yeah,
how much megafauna there was in the
early days of homosapiens moving across
North America.
There were two ton sloths,
giant sloths and one of just vanity
vanity.
Many massive mega fauna that we just
don't have anymore.
Yeah.
The blitzkrieg hypothesis is what they
call the human animal,
killing off all the other animals.
It's a really troubling hypothesis
because we don't want to think that
we're capable of doing that,
but obviously we do do that.
I mean,
we're doing it right now.
We did it to the buffalo and then we
almost went to the Bison Dodo.
We're doing it just a Tasmanian tiger.
There's a lot of different animals that
within our lifetime have gone extinct.
I mean,
where it actually like in terms of
extinctions,
um,
I'm not sure if we'll get the number,
but um,
it would be pretty accurate to describe
this as the fourth and make show mass
extinction because it's just huge.
The number of species have gone extinct.
So this human activity and it's also one
of those things where we don't think of
it as being significant because it
happens slowly over the course of many
years.
But if you look at it on a timeline,
you're like,
oh my God,
look,
everything's dying right now.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
So it's slow by human standards fairly
quick by nature,
logical standards.
It's a fascinating subject.
The end of the ice age happening so
quickly,
the animals dying off so quickly and so
many large mammals dying off so quickly.
So when you think about what we know
people have done,
like when we almost killed off the ice
and they know why they did that,
we know how they did that and they did
it with extraordinary weapons and they
did it with high powered rifles.
They could shoot things from a far
distance.
They did it by shooting off trains.
I mean they did a lot of crazy shit back
then.
So we understand mean and there's a lot
of physical evidence.
You.
There's photographs of the actual piles
of bones and all that crazy shit when
you,
when you take away those physical
capabilities,
the extraordinary physical capabilities
like even riding on horseback.
There's a guy named Dan Flores who's a
fascinating guys,
a scholar who believes that even without
the Europeans coming over here and
market hunting and killing off all the
bison,
he thinks just the firearm and the horse
with the native Americans,
it's entirely possible that they were
going to eradicate the bison on their
own.
I mean,
again,
it just depends about timescales,
so even if you're just killing like
slightly more of the species,
like killing just enough of the species
that they're now below the,
you know,
two children for every two minutes.
Viability stage.
Yeah,
exactly.
Then just over sufficient time and
remembering the homo sapiens between the
hunter gatherer age was 190,000
years.
A very long time spans.
Again,
very short geologically.
But um,
yeah,
a very long time span.
So again,
just a,
you don't have to be killing that many
woolly mammoth to delight them to
extinction over the course of several
thousand years.
What are your,
when it comes to like the ethical
reintroduction of animals that have gone
extinct?
Like there are some people in Russia
that are constant.
They're currently rather working on some
form of a woolly mammoth.
We're going to take woolly mammoth DNA
from some of these frozen bodies that
they've gotten.
They've gotten some pretty intact woolly
mammoths now and they're going to try to
clone one.
Yeah.
So I don't know the details of how this
will work.
I guess they have to just stay to in an
elephant,
um,
but I mean,
I think it's like scientifically
interesting.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it,
but what are they trying to make them
like where you have woolly mammoths
everywhere.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think,
um,
I don't think there's any ethical
imperative to do it.
I think there's not a competitive.
Not like I would think just if there's
more wooly mammoths that's the same as
just being more um,
elephants and it might be a scientific
interest.
I heard,
um,
wild with like hypotheses that we heard
and we're like,
oh,
that's cool.
That sounds ridiculous.
Um,
yeah.
I heard the idea was leading,
introducing woolly mammoths to like
stump down snow in order to prevent.
Yes.
Prevent global warming.
Global warming can slow it down somehow
or another.
Yeah.
There's definitely things that sort of
thing that people say over dinner,
but yeah,
with the idea wasn't just stomped down
snow but also to eat the foliage.
Okay.
Yeah.
There was like some exfoliating thing
that they're doing where they would
consume so many trees and so many plants
that it would actually lower the
temperature of the earth.
What in the fuck?
Yeah.
Just seems skeptical of that.
But I mean,
there is this philosophical question of
whether you should.
So the question of biodiversity loss,
um,
which has been huge.
Um,
how do you value that?
So is it the case that loss of a
species,
um,
you can just cash that out in terms of
impacts on individuals because obviously
it's bad for the animals that die in the
course of that and it's,
we maybe have a loss of kind of
information that we can just not get
back.
But is there something intrinsically bad
about just having fewer species and a
lot of people seem to act to act in a
way that suggests they seem to believe?
Yes.
Um,
but it's hard.
I think it's hard philosophically to
cash that out.
Um,
I think it's hard to explain like why
would we care so much about losing
species where we don't seem to care
about having,
you know,
deliberately randomizing.
I'm bleeding and so on that we get more
species.
Um,
it seems like we're only just
conservative about not losing them,
but if it really is a value to have
greater diversity of species,
why do we not actively find,
promote greater amount of bio diversity
of other merely preventing loss of
biodiversity.
The,
I think the reintroduction,
the reintroduction of species.
It also like if you have an environment
that's stable,
have you have some sort of an ecosystem
that's stable and then you reintroduce a
Predator or prey or some animal that's
gonna eat up all the foliage.
It's you,
you're running this big risk and you're
taking these big chances that you can
sort of predict the future.
You could look at a plus b equals c,
but it doesn't always work that way and
there has been disastrous result results
when they've introduced species,
um,
to other environments where they're not
native.
Like,
you know,
what's going on with places like
Australia.
Australia is kind of hilarious in that
regard.
Yeah.
So they introduced the lab.
No,
the institute a type of flog to a slave.
I'm going to butcher this as well,
but the entities type of flag to
Australia,
it took over,
so they introduced a lab at suitland,
eat these blogs or something to eat the
bugs and then they took over and didn't
kill the bugs and I think they
more than boxes to try to kill the
rabbits and they killed all the ground
nesting birds and they introduce cats to
kill the foxes and I mean you have to
kill the rabbits.
That's fact back ward attending
introduced species,
especially back then,
you know when they were doing this in
the 18 hundreds in Australia,
they really didn't know what the fuck
they were doing.
They're thinking short term right in
front of them and they also brought in a
bunch of animals that don't have natural
predators,
so they have to gun them down from the
fucking sky.
I mean they have these,
all these deer and stags and all these
magic beasts.
I mean if you ever seen a stag,
they're incredible.
They roar.
They sound like a lion and they have so
many of them in Australia and
particularly in New Zealand,
but they don't have any natural
predators.
Zero,
no predators,
so they have to fly over and helicopters
and gunned them down.
It's just like.
And they leave them.
They just leave them to rot.
They just have too many of them.
Same with Kangaroos as well.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I've seen those herds of
Kangaroos.
He ever seen that?
No,
I haven't.
Oh my God,
there's a video that some guy took
somewhere in Australia and it is
thousands and thousands of kangaroos
running across this field and it looks
like a,
like some apocalypse apocalyptic
kangaroo invasion.
See if you can find that Jamie the video
just because it's worth seeing two to
realize like,
oh,
this is what can happen when there's no
predators.
Like animals just get completely out of
control.
Yeah,
so I'm vegetarian and have been for a
long time now,
but with some other vegetarian fence we
had the conversation of yeah,
what would be the most ethical meat to
eat and I think we can concluded that
kangaroo would be the most ethical
because it's being killed anyway because
they just need to,
like,
you've got this population explosion.
It's on land that wouldn't be otherwise
used for anything,
you know,
haven't been fully.
They've got good lives.
Um,
the environmental impact is therefore
going to be um,
you know,
low or nonexistent as well.
Um,
obviously it,
kangaroo meat is very unusual and almost
all of those,
the guards,
it's not though.
Yeah,
I mean it's very nutritious.
Apparently
Kangaroos is actually a type of deer,
believe it or not.
Yeah.
I don't believe that marsupial which has
a totally different.
It is,
but it's related to the deer in some
strict look at these fuckers just
hanging out.
This is not the one I'm talking about
though.
There's a bunch of them running across a
field.
This is just a large population of
kangaroo.
Yeah.
Some way in the deer family and some
strange way.
See if Jamie could find that too.
Do you know that we have wallabies in
Scotland?
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
In an island called inch Konica.
Yeah,
I've heard of that.
I've visited them a number of times.
And were they introduced to Scotland?
Yeah.
So late the oven Kahuna had that bitch.
Well no need for that.
So she,
I'd actually don't know,
but she owned,
she owned the island.
She owned the zoo on the island,
like a personal zoo.
Um,
and she,
uh,
died I think there lou the zoo went to
back and everyone.
So it just kind of was a while,
but he's just got out and the wallabies
took over.
Yeah.
First evidence because people wouldn't
likely visited this was they would find
these dead wallaby caucuses on the
mainland and that was during the winter.
The law,
Scottish for lake would freeze over and
the wallabies would hop on the ice when
you get hit by a car,
but then now very tame.
It was a shame because I first found out
about them back when it was still a bit
of a seek.
That was fascinating and now it's become
a bit of a tourist hotspot.
Wow.
Says that Kangaroos are marsupials and
more closely related to possums than
deer.
Oh,
okay.
So they're not related to dear mean.
Correct.
Yeah.
Someone had told me that there were in
some way in the deer family or cousins
of deer or something like that.
Early explorers said that they were just
what their descriptions were.
They were like deers without antlers and
they stood up.
Right.
Like men,
but a salsa.
I mean,
it's a cure a question.
So I didn't find like an official
scientist saying here's deciding on it,
but uh,
yeah,
that's what I wish I had this my whole
life.
Someone who could just follow me around
and correct me if the time I say
something about this,
this is an amazing time.
Somebody puts something up on instagram
today and it was a a quote from the 18
hundreds about an ancient philosopher or
an ancient scholar rather would give his
life for the information that's
available to the common school boy
today,
and this was from a quote from 18,
88.
Wow.
Which is nothing now compared to what we
can do.
Yeah.
I think there was another statistic,
and again it's unclear how do you
measure this,
but in terms of letting the information,
at least one newspaper has yet more
letting the information in it than a
typical person in the 17 hundreds would
be exposed to for the entire lifetime.
I wonder what.
What was the natural Predator of
Kangaroos?
Because kangaroos are.
They're a native animal to Australia and
if they
didn't,
do you know,
there was a giant Predator in New
Zealand at least at one point in time.
It was called the Haast Eagle and it was
an enormous eagle.
The biggest eagle.
They think that ever lived and had
something like a 10 foot wingspan and
they believe that even hunted people who
have huge,
huge eagle and it's a part of the.
I guess it's the Mowery,
it's a part of their ancient mythology
and they found out that it is actually a
real animal.
That was somewhere around the 14
hundreds was made extinct through
hunting.
My understanding was in Australia before
humans invaded crocodiles.
My understanding was it was just no
major predators for um,
that's the Tasmanian Tiger
thylacine yeah.
They call that thing the Tasmanian Tiger
that died during human,
like modern Thompson's.
It's a crazy looking picture,
but it's face will get that mouth on
that thing.
Jesus Christ.
But that I believe those things
died off in the cities.
I just typed this in here,
this,
that it's now extinct,
but the Dingo is probably the more
Predator they had.
When did it die?
Thylacine is now extinct.
However,
humans arrived in Australia at least
50,000
years ago and introduced the Dingo about
5,000
years ago.
So maybe those things were tank
Kangaroos were a big part of Kangaroos,
I guess would probably catching them
when they're not with.
They're young,
but they carry their young inside their
body in that pouch,
which makes them different from any
other kind of animal that it would be
prey because they can take care of their
young and bounce away quickly.
Well,
this is why.
So in terms of large mammals,
humans killed every single type of large
mammal other than Kangaroos in
Australia.
I think they were kind of hundreds of
different types of originally.
Oh,
there's a bunch of different things
other than Kangaroos.
Yeah.
Like what again,
I don't know,
maybe giant Koalas,
let's say.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah.
And,
and my understanding was the reason for
that was because they didn't have
natural predators.
Um,
and so they just didn't know what to do
with people.
So that makes sense to have all of these
defensive mechanisms there and also have
wolves and coyotes and bears and all
these different things that are chasing
them down.
That's interesting that the concept of
what's the most ethical thing to eat.
I would think you would think it would
be like mollusks.
Okay.
So that's.
Yeah.
So I do think it's totally fine to eat
anything.
Well,
what I say is I don't eat anything with
a plane.
So that means the oysters mussels,
clams they have.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm sorry,
I got convinced I didn't use to be like
this.
I got convinced by.
I'm an advocate for gets called by valve
veganism.
I mean it's not,
doesn't make a big difference.
I don't really like these things.
Eat them occasionally,
but you don't like,
like muscles.
No.
Really?
Yeah.
No.
Have you ever had linguine with muscles?
Like at a good Italian restaurant with
a,
a nice red sauce?
Yeah.
I mean,
so when they're good,
define and when the bad really bad in
that case with everything.
No.
Some things when they're good they can
grows hamburgers.
I mean,
you,
you can get down the line,
you know,
you could rotten food.
No,
but like,
you know,
good pizza is just amazing pizza or
like,
um,
like I feel like my,
the fatty best muscles.
I'm like mad towards a really?
Yeah.
Oh man,
you need to go to a really good Italian
restaurant.
I ever had linguine with clams,
do like clams.
So again,
I just feel I feel pain differently.
Bedroom.
Oh,
she's crazy.
You just need to go to a really good
restaurant.
You guys are eating in England,
man.
That's the problem.
They don't know how to make Italian food
there.
Yeah,
that's the great Indian.
I mean there's a few people right now.
They're screaming in England,
oh,
I'm a good Italian.
So you son of a bitch.
I'm generalizing and I'm aware I'm an
ignorant and saying that,
but I can't defend English.
Cuisine.
Great.
Having been out to New York,
San Francisco,
London has some amazing restaurants now.
London does.
You know what I mean?
But it was always the generalized
stereotypical knock.
Was it?
The Food in England was terrible the
first time I went there.
It was pretty bad.
But yeah,
with respect to what's the most ethical
meat?
I think it is a really interesting
question because I think,
you know the debate and vegetarianism
and so on.
It's normally face to this either or
thing like not doing anything or just go
vegetarian or Vegan.
Um,
but I was interested in this question of
just,
yeah,
well supposedly you only want to go
halfway or of the different foodstuffs,
like what are the,
what are the ones that are going to do
the most in terms of animal welfare if
you cut them out?
Because most people when they go halfway
to being vegetarian,
they might cut red meat,
beef and so on.
And I actually think if you care the
least about the animal welfare side of
things,
I think that's just long and I think
there's two reasons for that.
One is a one,
it's the respect to the amount of
suffering that the animal has in the
course of its life where the way that
chickens are couldn't lead to the tip.
If you look at just average,
and again we're talking about most
Checkins,
the,
you're talking about factory farming,
fish farming conditions,
which is well over 90 percent.
I think 99 percent of chickens they've
eaten other than these conditions that
life's just,
I think they're the worst stuff.
Creatures on the planet basically.
Um,
and cows I think often don't have great
lives,
but it's just nothing really compared to
chickens.
And I think poker is similar,
like pigs also have really terrible
lives.
Um,
whereas yeah,
large animals,
cows,
a sheep just in general aren't being
treated as badly.
And then the second question is,
um,
how many animals are you affecting where
if you,
um,
consumer steak or something that's like
a thousandth of account when I finished,
whereas you can easily eat kind of half
a chicken and that's a factor that
people normally don't consider those as
well.
And obviously maybe you value a cow's
life later than a chicken's life or
something.
We do in some strange way the hierarchy
that you have almost inherently,
or at least we do in the western world.
Yeah,
I think it was really hard to know,
like this is one of the hottest
philosophical question I've thought
about phages and have essentially given
up on this.
You've got an unhappy cow day and
unhappy chicken tell you which is,
which is where I had to wait.
Those two can't or an unhappy fish.
People have very few feelings about
fish.
Let me,
you see a dead fish.
People don't feel the same way.
They feel if you see a dead lamb.
Yeah.
But in general life become more
sympathetic.
I think there's a bias where we tend to
sympathize more with things that look
like us.
Fish have these weird kind of look.
They don't take care of the young too.
That's cute.
Yeah.
And so over time I've definitely become
a lot more sympathetic to taking
suffering of chickens and fish fairly
seriously.
Um,
and I,
I think when you combine these two
factors of,
um,
again,
yeah,
fish,
I think except that there's less good
information on them.
But um,
I think this might be in the category,
but certainly chickens and pigs compared
to beef.
I actually think if you just want to
kill,
like take out most of the suffering from
your diet,
removing chickens,
cage,
then caged eggs.
I think in the US actually that's
basically all x,
unless you can show them yourself.
Um,
and pork,
I think you're the moving and maybe
fish.
I think you moving most of the suffering
from your diet vastly more than when it
comes to before milk.
Yeah.
Well in terms of the amount of
individuals that get impacted your
writing,
that one cow can feed much more people
obviously then one chicken cancer.
So if you're taking one life and that
form,
what disturbs me most about factory
farming?
Well,
for one thing that disturbs me,
it sort of existed and then I found out
about it and it was already there and I
had been eating it all along and that
shocked me in that I was sitting.
I remember sitting back,
I'd watched some documentary on it and I
remember sitting back thinking like,
this happened because we weren't paying
attention because I was a grown man.
When I found out about it,
I hadn't been paying attention.
And when you leave people alone and you
say,
hey man,
do you think you can get us some beef?
That guy's like,
yeah,
I got it.
Don't worry about it.
You just stay over there and your city.
I'll take care of it over here.
Out of sight,
out of mind,
and then when we find out about it and
then you hear about in America we have
these things called ag gag laws.
I'm sure you're aware.
It's unbelievable.
Like no possible justification for this
terrifying.
It's just because.
So yeah.
Whets their hiding information.
Hiding information.
Yeah,
and there was a case where there was an
animal welfare activists goes into a
factory farm is filming instances of
animal cruelty for of documentary film
that gets presented and she got fired
and had to go to prison for not
intervening in the animal cruelty.
That was just happening all the time and
she was,
the person is actually about.
So she got tried for intervening,
not stopping the animal cruelty.
We just haven't to maintain all of the
time.
I thought she would get tried for
violating the AG gag laws.
No.
Well she was an invasion of privacy on
the corporation.
The corporate secrets.
Yeah.
I think it was applied to the Ad Guy
Louis.
Oh.
So they found another way to try to
discourage that.
Yeah.
So that's so insane.
But the thing you said earlier,
which when you're talking about the ways
in which humans are broken,
I think if you just look at,
yeah,
suffering the humans of inflicting now
the thing that's really wanting is how
mechanized it's become.
So if imagine if.
Yeah,
there was even,
let's say a chicken just like here in
front of us.
I ain't just for fun,
just kick it.
Um,
people would be outraged.
People would just think I'm this kind of
despicable person and that's the natural
reaction because I'm just inflicting
unnecessarily suffering on this
creature.
But then you can just modify the
circumstances such that this natural
emotional reaction of sympathy just
fades away where now it's this huge
warehouse and it's not just one chicken.
It's hundreds of thousands of chicken
and it's all mechanized and it's all
taken out of sight.
I'm suddenly.
Yeah,
I mean just Stalin said,
yeah,
single death is a tragedy,
a million deaths statistic,
um,
and life lessons for them stolen.
But,
um,
uh,
it's an extremely good quote,
but he was telling about humans and you
know,
any death of a human will be tragedy and
when,
when they get to large numbers,
it's sort of,
it's very difficult to calculate because
it's hard for people to understand or
grasp the concept of a million people
dying.
What's bizarre about factory farming is
that it's all kind of done behind these
warehouse walls.
It's all undercover and it's all
incredibly common and it's all not
discussed.
This was happening.
Mike was going to say the wars happening
and 100,000
people a month are dying or discussing
how do we mitigate this?
How do we stop this?
How do we,
how do we bring peace?
There's so few people wondering how to
stop chicken suffering.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean because we've looked into this
and one of the reasons it's such a
priority area is just the amount of just
philanthropic money going into this when
it's.
The focus is clearly on factory farming,
not sled dogs and so on.
It's in the low tens of millions of
dollars
trying to stop factory farming.
Yeah.
Or trying to mitigate it,
what is the solution like other than
going vegetarian,
vegetarian,
when have we reached this point?
So sort of like unmanageable point where
the population centers like Los Angeles,
New York,
whatever,
that don't grow their own food and have
gotten so massive that in order to fuel
these people with food,
especially with,
with animal protein,
you almost have,
have these setups.
Yeah,
I mean I think if you've got the
constraint of animal protein,
I mean,
I think the answer's probably still no,
but the other thing is you just don't
need that constraint of animal protein.
We eat way more meat than we did.
Um,
you know,
50 years ago,
100 years ago,
I'm far more than we need to have a
healthy diet.
I mean,
I've been vegetarian 11 years.
Do you eat eggs though?
Free range eggs?
Um,
yeah,
I do.
Um,
that's for me.
I don't understand when people don't
like when Peter had that whole campaign
about eggs or chickens periods,
I'm like,
look,
I can understand you not wanting to eat
factory farmed chickens,
eggs because these animals are tortured
and they're confined and it's horrific,
but you can definitely find eggs and I
have my own chickens.
I have 22 chickens and they lay eggs and
I eat their eggs all the time and I ate
five of them this morning.
They're great,
but when you're talking about those
eggs,
there's.
There's no suffering.
The eggs come out,
they don't become a chicken.
You take them.
It's free and those chickens,
by the way,
there are a bunch of little murderers.
They run around my yard.
I've seen them eat a mouse before.
If they found a bird that was down like
a,
like a nesting bird that had fallen out
of a nest,
they'll fuck that bird up.
Anything that's on the ground.
The only thing they don't seem to like,
they don't seem to like slugs.
Okay.
You've tried to feed them?
No,
they eat them.
We pick up a rock in my garden.
I'll pick up a rock and they should have
come over and just jack anything that's
under the rock.
They figured out that when I lift up the
Rock,
there's bugs under there,
there a little murderers,
man,
they're ruthless.
They don't like slugs.
They try them and then they start
shaking their head.
They tried to get the slime off their
beak and it kind of freak out.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I mean,
this,
this big within the animal welfare kind
of animal activists,
this is actually quite big divide
between,
um,
you could call them maybe the
abolitionists to one side and the
feminists and the abolitionists.
The view is just,
you know,
animal.
The way we treat animals is like how we
treated slaves.
This is just,
this is kind of the equivalent of
slavery.
The amount of time and the only end,
you know,
imagine if we'd been in slave owning
Americans had like,
Hey,
well why don't we just cut down the
number of slaves?
It's just not doing nothing.
They'll model csns,
um,
the welfare lists in contrast,
a more like,
look almost oldest something.
If we're going to quantify the soft
thing of the way humans,
the animals know 99 percent of it comes
from factory farms.
If we could eliminate and factory farms,
sure,
there's still something left.
It's not like even if you could a went
on the kind of final stage,
but this is where the vast majority of
both the animals used under the worst
conditions are.
And so the welfare would instead say,
look,
let's literally just focus all of that
attention on this and things like
theater and eggs or services or um,
for just these are just literally kind
of not the main issue.
And um,
you know,
I'm naturally most sympathetic to the
kind of welfare perspective.
Um,
but it is interesting of the animal.
I know lots of people who were in the
welfare this camp and then moved to the
abolitionists camp on welfare.
The clowns were.
The kind of Wiley is just that.
If you're just an to get people to do a
little,
then you're not actually going to move
them at all.
Whereas you need to have this hard moral
line and then people kind of see the
integrity of that follow up.
Well,
it seems to me that there's a slippery
slope when agriculture and civilization
were introduced that someone wasn't
going to exploit it to the nth degree
and finger while it's just got to be a
better way to squeeze money out of this
situation.
And then next thing you know,
you've got these factory pig farms.
Sure.
You've seen those horrific one where
they fly the drone over the lakes of pig
pis and pig shit.
Absolutely.
That these animals are living just
completely confined where they can't
even turn around and they're just
pumping them up with whatever the fuck
they need to keep them alive until they
get to a certain point where they can
kill them.
Yeah,
and it is through people.
So many people would be.
Absolutely.
If that was lightly and fund,
it would be second.
Yeah.
Hence the AG gag laws.
In order to keep that money coming in,
they have to keep people in the dark of
these situations unless they go online
and seek it out and watch these videos.
And those videos are very polarizing too
because,
you know,
when you come to a lot of these animal
rights organizations,
a lot of them have roots in the Animal
Liberation Organization,
which doesn't even believe that you
should have pets.
They think that your pets are all
prisoners.
Yeah.
It's so interesting.
Going back to Peter Singer were,
you said the animal liberation,
which was the name of his book,
which was kind of text founding text for
what became the animal rights movement.
And what's interesting is the singer
doesn't believe in rights.
He's a consequentialist.
CC,
utilitarian.
Never used the word once.
So what he,
his approach would just be thinking,
yeah,
what's going to do the most good.
Um,
and on the pets question,
um,
no,
don't want to speak for Peter,
but he's going to think,
well,
if they have a good life and the world
teetered just seems fine.
Men,
he'd want to say like,
the focus should be on suffering.
Yeah.
On the huge,
vast magnitudes of suffering that goes
on in factory farms.
That's with one,
two,
three,
and four.
Yeah.
I have a hard time even entertaining the
conversation that there's something
wrong with a healthy pet dog like that
dog loved the owner.
The people love the dog and the dog has
obviously gone through an incredible
evolutionary process where it's gone
from being a wolf to being a Chihuahua.
Like if you think that thing should be
out fending for itself and the forest
boy,
you're dooming that little fucker to
death.
Well,
the question that dog in all of these
cases,
like the animals wouldn't exist
otherwise and that wouldn't exist from
people.
I mean if it wasn't for people breeding
them and making them this bulldog like
this thing that can't even hardly
breathe and walks with a wattle like
we're weird that we've done that in the
first year place.
Yeah,
I mean I find especially the pets like
dogs that have.
Yeah,
like difficulty thing,
genetic diseases.
I find it kind of goes like this,
gross that we've kind of done that.
I've gotten one.
What type of
dog do you have?
A Shibu Ino English bulldog mix.
Some poor little fucker.
He's a mess.
We got him as a puppy,
you know,
because he was cute and he just seemed
like it needed a home and we took
Amanda.
God,
he's all messed up man.
I mean I've had them for 10 years.
He said all these surgeries and can't
walk right?
His hips are all fucked up.
He's just like,
they breed them to the point where he's
half sheebu.
He knows he's actually better off than a
lot of bulldogs because he's 12 now.
I don't think bulldogs usually live that
long.
I don't think they lived to that age,
but he's got all sorts of difficulties.
Can't really run.
No,
he's lazy.
He just likes to lay down snore.
But the poor little things like if you
look at an actual,
like legit English bulldog with their
flat faces,
like they have massive respiratory
problems and yeah.
So I find that like the fact that we
like engaged in this paddock,
depleting them kind of weird.
But then like,
yeah,
if you're going to have a dog and look
after that,
well like it's not the problem.
And so this,
this question is just if you're talking
about that,
oh you just like distracting from the
main issue which is coming.
So seems to me that,
that this is just like everything else
in life,
like as you go down the rabbit hole and
you look at a deeper and deeper and
deeper,
you go,
God,
this is a complicated issue.
You know,
how do you get all these people to stop
eating so much meat so that you don't
need so much meat so that you don't need
factory farming and have to get people
aware of what is the consequences of
going and buying a chicken sandwich?
Well,
do you know where that chicken came
from?
Here?
Check this out.
Are you happy now?
And a lot of people,
they watched those videos and then
they'd go,
ah,
fuck it,
I'm hungry.
I want a chicken sandwich.
Yeah,
lots of people do.
I do think though,
like so in the UK at least if you buy a
pack of cigarettes,
you get these pictures on them showing
kind of what this is,
what the lungs will look like if you
smoke 20 a day and those warnings and
things.
Yeah.
That doesn't stop people in some weird
way.
I mean people are addicted to sick of
that so I think it must have some
impact,
but I wonder it does.
If you could buy a pack of chicken and
you'd say,
well this is,
this is this field of piss and shit.
That chicken grew up in.
Right?
Like the opposite of an ag gag law.
Like force it in your face because look,
I mean you're just giving the consumer
more information.
Having that.
Like if you went to the butcher shop,
went to the butcher section in the
grocery store and there was videos that
were playing constantly above the
package meat that showed these animals
getting like a piston through the head,
hanging by their ankles and getting bled
out while they kicked.
Oh,
and how many people that would be a
fucking conveyor belt of baby mail
checks falling into this.
I'm getting ground up.
That would be a fascinating
psychological examination to watch
people walk up to that butcher shop and
see those videos playing.
Like if that became the law.
Yeah,
I mean there's,
there's an amazing.
It was a comedy sketch show that um,
did something kind of similar,
which was the bill would go up to
the butcher's counter and say,
okay,
I'd like some sausages.
They go,
okay,
pick up a little baby pig at good to,
into this box.
This box is obviously fake.
And just like,
do this action in sausages would come
out.
Obviously they're not actually getting
it right and people will be out late and
it's like,
no web.
She not know where pork comes down.
So yeah,
that's the thing that's just amazing is
how people can call themselves an animal
lovers.
Well there's also
people that love animals and eat meat,
like they'll eat steak and then get mad
at people for hunting animals.
I've,
I've experienced that personally.
This is a good case though,
of the salient issue where,
um,
I mean,
so I have like a post hunting and bad
fandom that gets killed,
but the thing is it's so salient
compared to factually farming and it's
like,
you know what,
I prefer that people hung meat other
than like factory farming.
It's like,
of course,
and like you do the math,
it's like not only am I behind that and
behind that like a thousand times.
Again,
the hunting is just,
it's this fairly salient thing,
you know,
in the UK,
a huge uproar about fox hunting and so
on.
But that's a different thing because fox
hunting,
you're not,
you're not eating it now.
I mean it's supposed to be for.
Yeah.
It's Kinda like I'm in control.
And there's some,
there's some logic to that that if you
don't have natural predators,
you need to figure out some way to
control certain populations that can be
damaging like Fox or in some places
black bear.
And there's a bunch of different animals
that you do have to control because they
don't have,
they don't have a natural predator.
Yeah.
But the thing that's like incredible for
me,
it's just how people can have such long
views on that and such long views on
hunting and then just eat me know the
actions effectively.
Farming.
Yeah.
They just don't see it,
you know,
it is just because we have value
manipulable.
Is he in terms of a model,
the action.
Well there's obviously a wedding because
there's certain that you have.
There are certain animals that you have
to control the populations of less,
especially invasive species like pigs,
like wild pigs are huge problem in
America and getting bigger and bigger.
I know you guys don't have them as much
in the UK,
but in,
in America,
particularly in Texas and now in
northern California,
which is a massive,
massive populations of wild pigs and
they give birth two to three times a
year and they can give birth to as many
as three to six piglets in each lit and
they just caught and then six months
later those piglets are ready to give
birth.
So they just boom,
boom,
boom.
And if you don't control their
populations,
what are you gonna do you're gonna like
let wolves lose to control their
populations.
I mean they have to figure out how to do
it,
and so they've taken to a lot of the
same strategies that they're using in
New Zealand that we talked about,
what stags in Texas,
they have these helicopter hunts where
they fly around in helicopters just
gunned down hundreds and hundreds of
these pigs and they do wind up donating
the meat of that pigs to homeless
shelters and people who need it and it.
It's actually very nutritious and very
healthy and very good for you and that's
probably way better than buying pig from
someone who's raised it in some horrific
factory farming environment.
But for people that just want the
animals to live and be unchallenged in
on,
on preyed upon,
I get it.
They all seemed very disturbing,
but you got to control the populations
because you're not going to have any
agriculture.
They're going to find out where the
farms are and they tear them apart at
night.
They're nocturnal animals.
You can't stop them with fences.
They go right through fences,
they're huge,
huge animals,
wild pigs create millions of dollars of
damage in Riverside County.
Wow.
That's.
That's like Riverside county's like
super populated,
but this is a.
it's an enormous,
enormous problem in this country and by
the way,
when you look at that animal,
what's really cool about pigs is that
they morph.
When you see that animal,
it looks very different than a domestic
pig,
but it's exact same animal.
They're all the same genus,
so called [inaudible],
and when you take a domestic pig and you
let it go within months,
within months of being free,
their hair starts to change.
Their snouts starts to elongate.
Their tusks start to grow longer.
They,
once they become feral,
once they realize they have to fend for
themselves,
there's an actual physiological change
in the structure of their body.
So it's fascinating.
So it's really crazy.
Their hair gets thicker,
they develop a thicker plate the males
do around the chest to protect
themselves from other males when they
fight.
It's bizarre.
So those wild pigs that people see,
there's a bunch of different kinds.
Some of them are Russian boars are wild,
you know,
the different,
different kind of a pig,
but ultimately they all interbreed with
each other.
It's just so interesting as well.
Coming back to the question of what's
natural and so on,
people often think about meat that a
thing as well where if you look at the
chickens can barely stand because
they've been so engineered,
huge blasts,
you know,
pigs that you're talking about like,
uh,
not meant to be pink to be blown,
you know,
cows just can you really imagine a cow
like evolving in the wild are like,
of course not all of these things that
can edibly unnatural through thousands
of years of a selective leading.
Well crap cows don't live in the wild,
but here's where it gets interesting.
In Australia,
when cows have gotten wild,
they've gotten loose from these pens
that people held them in and then they
become what they call scrub bowls and
they're out there in the wild and people
hunt them like they would hunt a wild
animal and they're very wary and they
run from people.
They see people that get the fuck out of
there and the bowls are incredibly
violent,
like the,
the male cows.
These scrub bowls are some of the most
dangerous things to hunt in the world
because they'll actively chase you down
like a bull,
like,
you know,
if you see like people trying to ride
bowls and bowls kick and they go crazy.
All these scrub bowls are essentially
those bowls,
but many,
many,
many generations.
Wild.
So they're feral bowls.
Answer.
Yeah.
And so they,
they sort of were bred to be this
domestic thing and then they got loose
and then they became this wild thing and
so they look slightly differently.
That's what they look like.
That's a scrub bull.
So they're becoming slowly over the
course of many generations are more wild
animal.
So they,
they have these hunts for these
scribbles and if that thing sees you,
by the way,
that crazy look and bowl,
they will fuck you up.
There are some of the most dangerous
animals that you can encounter in the
wild apparently.
But,
uh,
I have a buddy,
my friend Adam.
Yeah.
They look different.
Like look at the Hump on its back,
I mean that looks like some crazy wild
African animal and it was originally a
long time ago of regular domestic cow,
so it shows just how officially they
are,
if that's just,
if that's the sort of changes you get
over just the course of a few generation
natural selection as opposed to what
we're doing with dogs.
You know when we create a bulldog,
I mean that is,
those are the animals that have survived
and and they've changed their
coloration.
Their physical structure looks different
in over many,
many generations.
It's quite,
quite fascinating.
Yeah.
It's like we have to figure out where we
stand I think in terms of the entire
ecosystem,
because we're certainly not viable.
We can't go out there and live amongst
those animals.
I mean we won't,
we'll get killed,
will get eaten.
We so we have to stay inside of our
homes.
We have to stay inside of our
environments and then we have to figure
out like how much of an impact should we
have on those things around us.
Should we be like all the other animals,
like all the wolves and all these other
animals,
the coyotes that have this impact on the
environment or should we try to lessen
our footprint to the point where we have
zero impact on any of the animals and we
just live inside of these sustained
areas that grow vegetation.
It's,
um,
it's an interesting question because
those animals prey on each other.
They all do.
And like,
what should we be a part of that?
Should we take place?
Should we take part in that?
I definitely don't think we should
factory farm.
I definitely think that that was a huge
mistake and I also definitely think that
that huge mistake is what led us to be
able to have these gigantic cities and I
don't think necessarily cities are a
huge mistake,
but man,
trying to figure out how to feed those
people in the way that they're
accustomed to eating right now.
There's a,
that's a massive,
massive battle.
Yeah.
But I think the kind of question of
large populations and how do you feed
them,
that massively tells in favor of flow
and meat consumption or vegetation or
because you've got this 10 to one little
way to create a category of meat.
You need 10 calories or more of,
um,
of they ignore soliah wherever you're
feeding them,
unless you're dealing with people just
consuming wild pigs.
Yeah.
Wild pigs.
Oh,
Kangaroos or something with no
exceptions to that as well.
But,
but I think there's enough to feed
people though.
That's the other thing.
There's 350 million people in this
country.
There's not $350 million wild pigs.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
but it means that in the future,
just as populations get larger than.
Yeah.
Again,
we're just going to need to use,
um,
landon energy more efficiently.
So this is yet another argument in favor
of a plant based diet.
Yeah.
Well,
in America at least,
the majority,
the vast majority of the money that goes
towards conservation,
towards keeping wild animal populations
high is actually from hunting.
It's a real strange contradiction that
makes people really uncomfortable once
they find it out,
is that the vast majority of the money
that goes to present protect habitat to
preserve wild lands.
It comes from hunting.
In fact,
hunters voluntarily agreed,
I believe it was in the 19 thirties,
to give up 10 percent.
I want to make sure that number's right
too,
but have the the money in terms of the
percentage of sales of hunting equipment
goes directly towards conservation.
There's all these things.
Yeah,
there's all these different entities
like the Rocky Mountain Elk Federation
that have repopulated elk into all these
areas,
but done so specifically so that people
can hunt them so it gets really weird,
like it might be an uneasy alliance
between in many people's eyes,
but they're the ones that are giving up
the money.
The money is not coming from altruistic
organizations.
It just want to preserve these animals
so that they can exist in the free wild
way that they did before people got
here.
But there's more white tail deer in
America today that when Columbus landed
so and that's all because of
conservation,
because of hunting.
So it's another one of those weird
things where at the whole picture,
yeah,
there's a solution that's I've heard
suggested for reducing species loss,
which is to um,
allow basically ownership of species.
So you can copy the panda.
I'm now,
isn't this a weird idea?
But the idea is that then now suddenly,
like at the moment,
no one has a financial incentive,
um,
to ensure that pandas don't go extinct.
Whereas if someone were able to say,
no,
I have,
if you want to use a panda and video or
so and you have to pay the owner.
Yeah.
Well I'm very uncomfortable with the
idea of this laboratory created meet as
to where that's going to go.
Why are you uncomfortable?
I'm very positive about it.
I mean the science is kind of tricky,
but I'm positive about it and that it's
not gonna be any animal suffering.
It's going to be fascinating in that
regard.
But what's going to happen if we find
out that,
well,
there's a bunch of different things,
right?
First of all,
we have to make sure that it's healthy.
We have to make sure that it doesn't
cause some sort of a weird disease
because you're not eating something
that's living and moving and when you
meet sedentary creatures,
maybe there's some sort of an adverse
impact on our biology because I think
there's an adverse impact when you eat
protein from an animal that is weak and
sick and they've actually shown that.
Um,
there was a study that Dr Rhonda Patrick
sent me recently that showed that
animals that eat older sick animals die
quicker.
They have a shorter lifespan and in
exhibit less health characteristics,
I believe it was than animals that ate
younger animals and there seems to be
some sort of a direct correlation
between eating younger healthy things
and having a positive impact on,
on physical life itself,
the animal that's consuming it and that
if you're eating something that never
existed in the first place,
like what?
Unless they're able to recreate the
characteristics of a healthy animal,
like a strong muscle tissue.
Like maybe they could do that with
electrical impulses,
like some sort of electrical muscles.
Muscular stimulation.
Yeah.
I don't see why that would be a problem.
I mean,
at least you'd think you'd be able to
get past that in fact,
where,
you know,
the meat that we've currently got
stuffed full of antibiotics,
um,
you know,
there's a often viruses that or
why this is the kind of aligned swine
flu,
flu.
Exactly.
You could avoid all of them with all
that.
All that stuff comes from factory farm
and in fact.
Yeah.
And in fact then once you start to
engineer meet,
perhaps you could engineer exactly the
healthiest sort of meat you've got so
much more control over the product.
There'll be crazy.
Of course you've got to,
yeah,
with development of any new technology,
you've got to be a cautious about it.
Um,
but ultimately it seems like we should
be able to get to the point where we
have tastier,
cheaper,
more healthy meat that uses far less
carbon like has far less carbon dioxide
as a side effect uses far less land
area.
It's going to be better than every
single way.
And I mean,
I think the science,
it does seem hard in particular just to
get the costs down low enough.
Well,
I think they've got it down pretty low.
I mean there was a recent article about
it,
whether we're talking about the original
one was worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars and now they've got it down to
like 20 bucks.
Yeah,
I think that was misleading wasn't.
it's a shame.
It seemed to me like there's a,
been a little bit too much hype in
between,
um,
where.
Yeah,
there's some stories of like the costs a
lot of [inaudible] going down.
Whereas,
um,
it's definitely much lower than that.
I think it's definitely still decades
away,
decades.
Yeah,
I think so.
Really what makes you think decades?
So the argument is that the currently
the,
so it depends on what you're talking
about.
I'm like,
egg white I think is Pez competitively.
Um,
milk is comparatively easy but
structured meet so you know,
steak or chicken that has a structure.
Um,
that's,
I think very difficult and I think
apparently part of what the difficulty
is there's a certain solution that you
need to go with this meat and,
and that solution is currently very
expensive.
Um,
and the key part of the cost and even
once we get to the point of being able
to develop this,
getting the costs down low enough so
it's,
it's competitive,
you're going to need to take this.
I'm fluid that currently costs,
I don't know how much,
like a thousand dollars a liter liter
get it down to the cost of soda and we
don't currently,
it seems like a clear kind of scientific
who would be the ultimate Turner
Syndrome if they found out that the only
way to make that fluid and to make it
financially viable is to make it out of
ground up.
Pets will get killed anyway.
Euthanized pet.
So at liquid people be upset if they
took euthanize pets and they used it to
make the fluid to grow the artificial
meeting or would they prefer those
euthanize pets just be cremated?
So at the moment that fluid does have to
come from animals.
Certain parts of it that is animal based
was just guessing.
Um,
so it's not exactly,
um,
ground up pets.
I'm just,
I understand it's still currently not
Vegan,
but it's interesting.
I think it's going to change.
I mean I do think given the level of
just model cognitive dissonance that's
currently going on,
people's attitudes to animals,
pets,
any animal they can see and consumption
of meat.
Once you take self infest out of the
equation,
once you've got meat that is cheaper and
just as tasty,
I think just everyone's going to switch
and then within a generation people will
look back at the current generation and
just think,
how did anyone ever engage in such
abominable activity as factory farmed
meat?
Yeah.
Well it's probably one of the darkest
things that we as a civilized humanity
do.
When you.
When you think about other than war,
which is obviously the most horrific
thing or one of the most horrific
things.
I mean it's arguable that in terms of
suffering,
it's the next thing because it's.
I mean it has to be the,
it is the next thing,
right?
So other than poisoning people for
profit,
you know,
other than companies that have polluted
environments that have won a poisoning
people.
Yeah.
So in terms of animals,
so 50 billion animals are killed every
year for human consumption.
Want worldwide,
most of them have kind of short life.
So a layer.
No,
broiler hens have six week lives.
That's crazy.
Six weeks.
So from the time they're incubated to
the time they're in a oven six weeks,
that's not.
Yeah.
And I think that nuts,
the point at which they die is that the
highlight of their life and my view,
because their life is just filled with
suffering.
And uh,
so that means any at any one time,
the 7 billion animals in factory farms
now living basically being tortured for
the entirety of their short lives.
So the entire population of the human
race,
it's basically one to one yet at any one
time,
isn't nuts
that,
that's less than 100 years old.
Yet much less than that.
Less than 50 years old.
Fifty years old.
Really?
That's the first crazy asshole that
jammed those chickens,
those little cages,
Henley field.
I think that's the guy.
His name.
So he fascinating it of the free
marketeers.
Um,
so back in the fifties I'm getting,
I'm going to go into a digression,
but it's not as bad as the affinity.
I promise you.
They're all awesome.
So back in the fifties I'm free market
economics was just completely dead.
That was just not a mainstream idea toll
within academic economics,
but it really,
if I was to prominence acos end of the
sixties,
certainly the seventies and then fetch
and logan getting empowered,
huge uptake in this intellectual
movement.
And so the question is kind of where did
it come from?
And it was actually very significantly
driven by a small number of people in
the fifties and early sixties.
Like very deliberately saying,
okay,
I want,
we want this ideology to become really
dominant.
And one of the most important first
organizations was the institute for
Economic Affairs based in London,
I think tank and it was funded by the
person who put the factory farm chicken
to listen.
So,
um,
it's weird because I promote this idea
of I'm earning to give as something that
young people should consider.
No,
it's the only thing that they should do.
But as one of many things they should
do,
a should consider doing.
If you want to do good,
you could go and like directly have an
impact.
But there is also another option which
is doing something you're really
passionate about that maybe has less of
a direct impact on a lot and donate,
um,
what you're making at least a
significant part of that to the things
you think are most important.
And then I think of this,
I think it's Henry Fisher,
sorry.
This is like this most perverse
instantiation of that where the guy
went,
became a factory farming entrepreneur.
Basically any ticket I give glands.
And so,
uh,
isn't that just so indicative of how
humans are so contradictory were so
complex and so strange and that we will
find all these justifications for all
these bizarre behaviors.
And then we were never like totally
pure.
Like there's so many,
so many people that are so that.
This is a terrible example,
but it's the one I use all the time.
Bill cosby made so many people laugh and
he raped about $100 or whatever.
Allegedly,
you know,
like he was helping and putting out so
much love to so many people and then
being fucking evil to a bunch of people
that he drug.
Yeah.
Or if they just know that this exists,
this duality that they think about Nazi
Germany,
you think about the number of people who
are involved in the Holocaust,
who loved their children and their
children,
and if you talk to them,
you would have had a great conversation.
They would have been very caring and so
on.
This is,
I mean,
yeah,
it's a very powerful idea.
The banality of evil.
I'm having events phase where,
yeah,
the worst crimes committed and not
because people are bad.
It's because [inaudible] not bad or evil
in the way that you think James Bond
villain like this person's plotting
something.
It's just because they have some goal
that is some goal in which they
indifference to suffering and the cause
that as a side effect.
And so it's the same if you ask people,
do you want animals to suffer that
ethically in factory farms will say,
no,
of course not.
It's just I don't care.
Casualties of war.
Exactly.
And casualties of civilization.
And the same insight actually when we
talk about ai as well as,
um,
you know,
sometimes in the media people say,
oh,
the worry about ai as a terminator,
it's going to want to kill humans,
but that's not the wedding at all.
The idea when you think about homo
sapiens and neanderthals,
again,
it's just having some other entity that
has goals on which you are just not very
important.
Right.
Um,
and that means that,
yeah,
well,
and they're also going to judge us.
I mean,
if they are intelligent and they are
superior to us,
they're going to judge us based on the
entire,
whole of our behavior.
And they're going to go look at this
messy species.
This species is crazy.
Elon mucks mosque has my most terrifying
quote.
Uh,
he,
his quote is the most terrifying to me
that he thinks that with ai we are
summoning the demon king,
the demon.
Yeah.
I love that quote.
That's just like.
I mean,
I want A.
Yeah.
Like I think a lot of the media
attention around ai is like,
has been really unfortunate because it
suggests like it's coming next year and
it's gonna Control.
It's like the demon.
I think anthropomorphized is necessarily
and so on,
sort of I think,
but if it's ultimate goals,
the extinction of the human race,
that's very demonic in our regard.
Yeah.
I mean it's more indifferent than sort
of the way we think about mollusks.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
The other way we think of like,
you know,
mosquitoes mosquitoes with my favorite
because vegans are slap mosquitoes.
Oh yeah.
I mean I'm get mosquitoes are not like
they're alive.
Yeah.
But are they like,
I think clams mollusks on 70 and then
insects.
I'm like,
well,
there's some weird arguments about that
then mean why not eat crickets?
Because cricket protein is excellent.
I've had cricket bars before.
They're covered in chocolate.
They taste really good.
They're high protein.
Many.
I do know many people who do advocate
for that.
My view is just like if you're unsure
then play safe.
MMM.
And you'd be eating a lot of crickets,
like.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of crickets out there
to you.
Well,
if you're,
could them like might be hunting tickets
with a tiny little spear.
I don't think I.
How you do it,
you're a lot more brutal than that.
I mean,
I think factory farming for crickets.
It'd be a horrific institution,
you know,
and you just.
What would you do?
Just fucking swarms of them.
The smash them down to a protein bar.
I would,
I worry about.
Is that,
what is the current number of the amount
of species that have ever existed that
are now extinct?
It's fucking huge.
90 nine point nine,
nine percent or something?
Why not us?
Oh yeah.
And if we do give birth to artificial
intelligence,
if we are the caterpillar that gives
birth to the butterfly that winds up
taking over the world some artificial
butterfly.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think the thing that worries me is
that,
you know,
it's ai is it's kind of its own thing.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
we do because it's like potentially
extremely beneficial as well.
And if it goes,
even if supposing it goes well,
then it's a huge thing like we should
care about it whether or not we're
worried about the extinction risk
because it's one of the things,
one of the later cases I think where we
can really see into the future and
think,
yes,
this is going to be a transformative
technology.
We don't know when it's gonna happen,
but when it does,
when it does,
it's going to be tons formative and it's
going to be very powerful.
And that means we should have some kind
of careful thought about it.
But it seems to me there's a variety of
ways that the human race could kill
itself.
Now.
So novel pathogens being one example,
large Hadron collider.
So my colleague toby actually wrote a
paper on the large Hadron collider
because there was always,
you know,
talking about,
oh we could hold and so on.
And so he either an academic paper where
he just talked about the risk analysis
that they did.
And they said,
oh,
the chance of the large Hadron collider
creating a black hole or something else.
It was like really dangerous.
Is Ten to the power of negative 60 feet.
You know what,
that's not going zero.
It's not zero.
Firstly,
it's not zero was motherfuckers that
could addiction.
What if we put the odds were really
long.
We didn't know.
But the second thing also is that,
um,
it's a,
you shouldn't think that anything's tend
to the negative 60 feet,
Bailey,
unless you have very,
very strong models behind,
right?
Because what's the chance that you just
made some mistake in your calculation?
It's like,
you know,
maybe it's as low as one in a million
that mistake completely swamped.
And so that was the point he was making
just statistical point saying,
look,
I'm not commenting on whether this is
dangerous or not,
it's just that you've made a mistake in
your methodology,
um,
with respect to your risk assessment.
And so it was really funny because then
he was there.
This is fairly calm,
sensible,
um,
you know,
a philosopher from Oxford in a meeting
with lunch either and Kaleida surrounded
by all the,
um,
you know,
uh,
elementum like tin foil,
tin foil,
hat people,
aluminum file minium.
I love the way you guys say aluminum
right now.
Apparently I'm.
I was so annoyed when I found this.
But penalty.
Your,
your way is correct and it's just a
weird area tire with an I really.
And
then you start saying things like click.
Oh,
there's a nice click of people in the
niche and the fire.
Oh,
you say it's a niche for for.
Yeah,
for.
Yeah.
We say for here though,
do people say four year?
So I've definitely heard for you.
Walmart people was a white trash.
Where are you from originally?
Where am I from?
New Jersey is where I was born because I
thought it was a New York thing,
but maybe,
maybe not.
Maybe I didn't really grow up there.
Grew up all over the place.
Boston mostly.
Yeah.
But you know,
you do.
You do so many things long.
It's very,
it's very distressing to me.
I'll tell you what we don't do.
We don't do Queens.
You guys still have queens?
I love the Queen Shit.
She's still going.
It's so funny.
I feel like every time I go,
no.
I think the queen is like hilarious
institution.
That's his job always to like wave and
this wave she just kind of rocks her
hand back and forth.
Some sort of weird semi vulcan stance.
Um,
it's Kinda funny.
Yeah.
Talking to especially some of the kind
of pick last of friends I have in a
medical,
like you've got a monarchy,
everyone talking about it.
If you guys like it's quaint.
Yeah.
We're just like no one really thinks
about her.
Right.
But she still lives in a fucking castle
and the castle,
she lives off the dime.
But if you do an economic analysis,
she brings in more money than she,
um,
sort of.
But she takes a lot.
She's sort of the anti will macaskill if
you asked me.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean the test is they support and she
just gets all this free money and that
bitch just wears gold and shit and
drives around in a limo.
It's kind of ridiculous.
So you could,
yeah,
you could definitely,
uh,
get the same tour.
Doesn't benefit people are mad.
I say,
bitch,
I'm not really meaning the word bitch,
so I could all due respect folks.
Just a figure of speech,
a humorous figure speech.
Okay.
Well I appreciate the.
Yeah.
I don't want to disparage your ruler.
The cliche,
the caveat.
Such a strange rule though.
Kings and Queens and Prince Charles.
It's really funny.
Pov that sculpture.
So I keep.
It's so funny because I keep.
I spent a lot of time in California,
but every time I come back it seems to
be on some major event to do with ilt.
So one was the queen's birthday,
one was the event of the Queens being
the longest ever running monarch.
When was the jubilee.
We don't know about that at all.
Those things for you is these massive
events.
It just means I come off the plane being
in America for a while and then it's
just pictures of the queen.
Everyone say okay.
Yeah,
I'm definitely back in play tea now.
Now what's going on now?
And I think crazy.
What's happening now.
Yeah,
huge news today.
What?
Um,
well for me as a skunk,
I'm Nicholas Sturgeon,
the first minister of Scotland.
A kind of think of Scotland to the UK is
state to federal level,
but it's a little bit different.
Um,
announced there's gonna be a second.
She's planning second Scottish
referendum.
So because the,
because Britain is taking yourself out
of the European Union where they expect
is that announcing can meet Tuesday end
of month,
but it's very shortly.
I'm,
Scotland did not want to leave.
The EU voted overwhelmingly in favor of
remaining.
So Scotland in general,
it tends to lean a lot further left than
the rest of the UK.
Um,
and previously had an independence
referendum.
It was very close,
actually 52 percent,
um,
within favor of staying apart for the
union.
So the state of the Union,
um,
there's now going to be a second
referendum.
These,
this is what Nicola Sturgeon is saying.
Um,
and because of the Brexit vote,
I think it's much more likely that
Scotland will say,
yes,
we're going to leave.
And then they have the main part of the
European Union where there's the last of
Litton,
um,
will leave.
And it's interesting for me because I
was very kind of play with the union
against independence in the previous,
um,
referendum now I'm not sure now,
I think I probably am in it because I
think that brexit was just such bad
decision,
um,
that I kind of want them to be punished
for that.
And well,
I think there's two things.
One is the,
um,
I think that now the case for Scotland
being part of the EU but not part of
Britain,
the economic case can,
it makes a bit more sense now than it
did in the past.
But then secondly,
just I would kind of worry that um,
Britain leaves the EU,
EU,
does that trigger kind of spark like,
you know,
a much larger movement where the just
the EU as a project kind of breaks down.
Um,
and if it's the case like,
well,
UK leaves the EU,
but as a result the country just falls
apart.
I think that you wanted that to happen.
You wanted England to fall apart,
to be punished for leaving the
be like a very major signal.
Like I don't think it would be.
What if they prospered?
They were,
oh yeah.
I mean then if it is,
if I do got.
If I was convinced that the blacks,
that was the late decision that was
actually best for the world and then I
would change my mind.
I don't know enough about it,
but I do have a friend who's very
knowledgeable and he's from England and
he.
His take on it was the real issue with
the EU is that you're dealing with a
bunch of people that aren't even
elected.
They're just sort of running the
European Union and he's like,
and we don't have to tell you when you
just look at history,
what happens when people have a great
amount of power and aren't even elected
to their position and you're allowed to
just go to any part of the European
Union and move into it.
He's like,
that was very detrimental and very bad
in terms of the way England's financial
structure was set up.
They were like,
this could.
This would be detrimental to England,
but beneficial to other places and the
idea was that we were supposed to accept
the fact that it'd be detrimental to
England and beneficial to other
countries and many people in England did
not want to do that.
And in doing and in making that
decision,
they were thought to be Zena phobic.
They were thought to be a nationalistic
and that it was racist.
So I think there's,
um,
yeah,
two things.
I mean,
one thing is yeah,
I don't like,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
so there's kind of two things.
One where the specter of their
sovereignty question,
um,
I mean like European Union,
like it has its own parliament and so
on.
You can vote on that.
You each get number of electors and the
reason in so far as it's undemocratic,
it's mainly just because people don't
care like the don't care democratic,
but t as in voter,
so turnout to have elections for members
of European Parliament.
The turnout is very low.
I think it's like 30 percent sort of
thing.
Maybe it will be larger now they realize
the consequences of it.
Well,
I mean,
there's not going to be anymore because
it's gonna,
it's gonna leave implode.
Well,
Benton's leaving Britain's leaving,
so you no longer voting for members of
parliament.
Um,
so that's one question and then like is
this good or bad split?
And um,
I think like the economic case is just
incredibly swung for European kind of
good for the reason being just like
fleet fade in general benefits both
parties.
You want to really maximize the amount
of fleet late.
Um,
but then the bigger thing for me,
it's just like with respect to unity
between countries is like the tail risk
risk of war,
which we don't really think about
because we haven't had a like a world
war since,
um,
you know,
the early,
mid 20th century,
um,
but Europe had had like a long period of
comparative peacefulness like before the
first world war.
People thought,
no,
it's unthinkable given the level of
interconnectedness between the countries
that are World War can play count and
intuited.
Right.
Um,
and so,
and I think those sorts of things would
be,
you know,
the tail outcome,
it can be very bad indeed.
Um,
and we don't often think about it
because it's just this occasional thing
and so that's why in general and just
always more like not all,
almost always more pillow.
I'm closer relations between,
um,
between companies
that makes sense to me.
Um,
what he said makes sense to me as well
though when he was saying essentially it
was like think of the United States,
but now think of each state being
country.
You're allowed to elect a leader of that
country,
but you can't elect a leader for the
United States.
And so that's essentially how he was
looking at the European Union.
He was saying the European Union is,
they're not elected and yet there are
controlling all these other elected
officials and elected state's all group
together instead of thinking of them as
like Germany and England,
think of them as states and think of the
European Union and the officials.
The people that are in control of the
European Union aren't even elected.
Yeah.
So I mean,
you do elect the parliament and then
it's also the case,
the analogy,
like the amount of power that Europe has
over the remaining the other countries.
It's like nothing like the amount of
power of the federal government,
the federal government has overstates
like um,
you know,
the UK sets.
So the power is the EU has one of the
things that are got made lots of
attention was bendy,
bananas.
This guy like a real focus area for
people's either also and what does that
mean?
So according to EU regulations,
so EU has a single market,
so that means you have just the same
standards across all countries,
but then that means you just start to
say have the standards of the things
like bananas.
And so there was one EU regulation which
was that a banana couldn't be too bendy,
otherwise it would count as a defective
banana.
And so people were like up and age about
this.
Like how can the EU dictate to us,
um,
the shape of our bananas.
But I think the case is like a good one.
It's like,
it's really not that important.
It's just a banana.
Why are they even going to regulate it
then?
Well,
it's because if you want to have like a
fee,
like single market,
you need to have common standards
across.
Um,
and then this was just marketing
standards were like the Bendy,
bananas don't sell and then the
straighter ones do.
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't know more of the detail about
that seems to be the time the government
steps in on something as fucking
ridiculous as the bend in the shape of a
banana and be like,
hey,
fuck face.
Why don't you go take care of poverty?
You know,
why don't you,
why don't you handle something real
instead of dealing with bendy bananas.
Look.
So on the Bendy Madonna's case.
Yeah.
I can't off the top of my head.
Think of why you'd want to not allow the
sale.
But that's what people worry about when
they worried about bureaucracy when you
worried about too much control.
Yeah.
So,
um,
that's a great example.
In fact,
why,
why people don't want micromanaging of
our culture.
Yeah.
But then the question is do we want to
leave over bananas?
And I think a lot of other factors,
it's not the bananas that caused it,
right.
But the thing is the UK as part of the
European Union has sovereignty over like
what's income taxes,
all of its laws as long as they don't
conflict with the UN Declaration of
human rights,
which was first invented by the UK,
has control of a,
um,
yeah,
all of it's internal,
um,
legislation,
it completely can go to war if,
once I'm undetected.
So the loss of sovereignty seems pretty
mild from my perspective.
And I feel like I feel like they focus
on these examples,
which is like,
okay,
maybe like let's say yeah,
it's okay.
It's a cost we would like to be able to
like maybe it'd be better if it could
make decision of men as maybe the
bananas was the bad coal.
Well,
it definitely doesn't seem like a
universal reaction.
I mean the,
the,
there's a large percentage of the people
in England are very upset about brexit.
No,
it's a really interesting sort of a
divide between people.
I mean,
the thing that I find fascinating is
that we would make,
and I think this in general,
I think this the elections as well
because I studied a bunch of voting
theory wanting my phd and we make these
momentous decisions as a country where
we get everyone in the population.
That's fine.
Go to a specific place and then get the
smallest possible information out of
them that you can,
which is just a single tick like yes or
no.
Whereas there's so much more you could
be doing.
So in one case with a referendum,
um,
rather than just at a particular date
where the turnout is affected by things
like the weather,
um,
it's affected by,
you know,
what happened in the week before and
instead you just have figured referenda
and given them a mountainous
momentousness of the decision,
spending more money on,
like actually getting the accurate views
of the people,
um,
is super important.
So instead,
yeah,
you have free over the period of six
months and choose the best,
um,
you know,
be best fee basically where there's,
that would be like a more accurate,
an accurate representation of what
people think of a time.
Sure.
But isn't there also a gigantic issue
with people not being informed about
what they're voting on?
You don't have to be informed about what
you're voting on.
You certainly don't have to be accurate
about what you,
you could easily be misled and the
actual hard,
provable facts could be completely
outside of your grasp and yet you still
make a big decision.
I wondered before about having a um,
attest attest.
Yeah,
you go like,
but like really,
really basic.
Um,
I think it would still.
There's this question of just why do we
care about democracy?
What's the point?
Why do we seems like a really important
thing?
Oh yeah.
Political philosophers talk about this
all the time.
So they kind of agreed like democracy
seems goods,
other forms of government that we know
so far seem terrible,
terrible,
or worse.
But why?
Why is democracy good?
Is it just that democracy gives us this
way to boot out dictators and the risk
of a single person taking power is just
really,
really bad and so we just need some
mechanism to get rid of that.
Is that it's intrinsically valuable?
Is it that people just have a right to
have equal representation and that's
just this fundamental thing?
Or is it justified on just in terms of
the consequences?
Is it because if everybody's able to
contribute then people will make better
decisions?
I never necessarily think it's an either
or.
I think there's also the people like to
feel like they play a part,
like they don't want to feel like
they're being ruled over by some
monarch.
They want to feel like they have some
sort of a play and the decision making.
It's also what one of the gross things
about trump winning in this country is
how many people gloated you know,
how many people gloat upon victory that
their side one and then you're dealing
with this whole team mentality that
people adopt when it comes to any sort
of an issue.
Well,
I mean this is cool,
right?
Right.
Yeah,
no,
in general,
this is one of the things I'm really
worried
about with,
um,
uh,
is increasing levels of partisanship.
This is just this really robust
phenomenon that we're seeing.
Um,
and it's really worrying because it
means that we're just undermining any
chance of people changing their mind.
Like someone,
like people say,
well,
it costs a commie accepted,
but like the vast majority of votes
were.
And similarly for Hillary's votes were
from people who just always voted
Republican or Democrat.
Well,
not necessarily
because the trump won by so many votes
that have good percentage of them had to
have voted for Obama.
Just statistically,
oh,
I'm,
I'm still thinking of thumps votes.
What proportion of people have only ever
voted Republican?
It's a good question.
And I would like definitely bet greater
than 80 percent negative.
Ninety percent.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
If you look at the polls,
like it's always that in terms of
expected number of votes,
like,
oh,
it's only 46 percent in favor trump with
his office.
So the issue that the independence and
the swing states,
whether it's Gary Johnson or whether
it's Jill Stein,
those independence,
the amount of votes they got would have
swung the other way towards Hillary.
Yeah.
I remember looking into this for Jill
Stein in particular,
and actually it was the case she would
have won the popular vote by even more,
but in none of the swing states,
did she get enough of a percentage,
not just Jill Stein or Gary Johnson as
well?
Yeah,
though Gary Johnson,
it seemed to me was split almost evenly
between trump and hillary.
But this is an interesting case.
So the thing that people.
Yeah,
I don't think about so much as like,
I think the process,
we all the sudden like a democracy,
but like one single,
I'm like check box every four years.
It's like the smallest amount of
information you can be getting and it's
susceptible to all sorts of different
things.
So it's opposing.
And this happens on both sides.
It's opposing.
Jill Stein became,
you know,
really,
um,
a really popular,
took 10 percent of the vote.
She would've just killed hillary like
absolutely or suppose.
And the Evan Mcmullin,
is that his name?
Yeah,
he was a Publican Independent.
Okay.
Did well in Utah and it was supposedly a
far right candidate.
It does really well.
Again,
takes all of the votes away from,
from um,
the fact that that's possible.
Shows that like first past the post
voting system is a very bad voting
system,
is not accurately representing the will
of the people and we could do so much
better than it would mean that I'm like
as a democratic process,
you'd be much closer to that.
Presenting what people actually believe
or feel about things because right now
it means that yeah,
you can be influenced by stuff.
Like how much support as a third party
get.
Well
System's terrible system.
It lasts too long.
The decisions last for four years.
This person gets locked into position
unless you impeach them and then remove
them from office.
They're stuck.
It sucks.
I wish I could talk about more,
but I can't.
I gotta
get the Fuck Outta here.
But uh,
this,
that's the least interesting thing we
talked about today.
But the ai and all the other stuff is
just fascinating stuff.
If people want to know more about your,
uh,
effective altruism movement and more
about you,
where should they go?
They should go to effective
altruism.org.
Um,
that's got tons of information about
effective altruism if you want to,
if there's one takeaway that you
literally want to do,
you think,
wow,
actually this was kind of cool.
I do want to make more of a difference.
We've just launched a set of funds so it
just means you can donate within one of
these,
cause that is a global development,
animal welfare or preservation of the
long run future against global
catastrophic risks.
You can just donate and have ensure that
we'll go to the vet.
He most effective nonprofits,
zero percent overheads depending how you
tonight.
And I'm like,
we don't take any money along the way
and just means that,
yeah,
super easy to donate as effectively as
possible.
All right,
beautiful.
Thank you.
Well appreciate.
It was really fun.
We'll be back tomorrow with Jim Norton
Seal.
Yeah.